Means Committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covid-19
pandemic in accordance with the house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically this is a public
hearing what bills referred to the ways
and means is a primary second committee
bills executive sessions on pending
legislation may be held
please note there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
the legislative staff have the ability
to communicate contemporariously during
this meeting to the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporariously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
now notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and irsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600 or email
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
I want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us Jennifer
floor committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance when each member
states their presence plays also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
okay representative Bernstein if you
take the
attendance thank you Mr chair and good
morning to you uh it's March 10 2021 903
a.m and you can smell spring in the air
let's begin roll call with
Representative Patrick abrami Yeah here
in my home in stratum my wife is in the
house representative Mary Griffin
representative ulery
here at home my wife someplace
representative Ober Aaron Hudson with
the six cats Representatives Doucette
alone in Salem
good morning your clerk is in Nottingham
New Hampshire in his home office by
himself representative Robert Elliott
here in Salem New Hampshire
um and my wife is in the other room good
morning sir representative John janigian
here in my home office in Salem and my
wife is somewhere in the house
representative Herschel Nunes good
morning Mr Clark and good morning
colleagues I am home alone in Pelham New
Hampshire
the very Dapper dressed representative
Tim baxton
thank you Mr Clark and good morning to
you and I'm home alone
representative spilsbury home alone in
Charlestown
good morning representative Tudor home
alone in Northwood
representative Susan Almy
all alone in Lebanon on there are two
people with telephone numbers and
attendees maybe one of them is Mary
we'll check at the end uh representative
Richard Ames
yes I'm here alone in my home office in
Jeffrey representative Southworth
um home alone in Dover representative
Malloy
at home in Greenland New Hampshire
yes I'm home alone in Randall good
morning representative gomarla
um home alone in Swansea and I've asked
Jen if either of those phone numbers are
people of ours
representative law representative gorg
good morning I am here and alone
good morning representative hacken
good morning good morning representative
James Murphy good morning I am in my
opponent Hanover thank you
and uh represent chairman Norman major
good morning I'm in my home office in
Plaistow and my wife was in the house
okay unless one of those phone numbers
is Mary Griffin Mr chair there are 22 of
not at this time
um I think
Mary could um raise her hand if it is
her and also I'm wondering if one of
them is representative Bixby because
he's first on the list to speak to his
bill
Jen remind them how to raise your hand
if you're on your uh star six to raise
star six to unmute and star nine to
raise your hand
Janine can you let commissioner Jasper
in yes
just an FYI Janine uh neither of those
numbers are Mary's okay
I just talked to my wife uh she talked
to Mary three days ago and she wasn't
feeling well at all
okay
um I'll also add representative major
that representative Pearl is in the
attendees and he's second on the list to
testify okay might as well let him in
okay
and that appears to be the only two
okay all right this is a public hearing
on House Bill 532-1
an act creating animal records database
we are the second committee being
referred to on this bill
the first committee environment and
agriculture
passed it and it passed the Full House
and we now have it and where to look at
anything that would affect revenues
so I would like to have the prime
sponsor
representative Bixby introduced his bill
and remember I was just going to speak
to the revenue aspects of this
uh we don't have representative Bixby
but we do have representative Pearl and
okay uh representative Pearl do you want
to introduce the bill
sure I can uh I wasn't prepared to do
that exactly so I'm going to swing it a
little bit good morning members of the
Ways and Means Committee uh for the
record my name is representative Howard
Pearl representative representing
Merrimack District 26 the talents of
Loudoun Canterbury Northfield Boston and
Ward 3 of Franklin
I'm here today to introduce House Bill
532 establishing a animal records
database excuse me
the uh so this bill as uh representative
major stated it came to the environment
and agricultural committee and it's a
bill that was in the works from last
year as well we made some significant
changes through the amendment process
when it came into our committee this
this bill does establish an animal
database and in its original form would
have uh tracked health certificate
transfers as well as it would have
included rabies certificates and there
was uh several fees that were associated
with the uh and with the health
certificates and the rabies certificates
can we spend a long time on this bill
especially behind the scenes
representative Bixby and I have probably
have close to 40 hours into fixing this
bill and making some changes and getting
it to the Fine form that is being
presented to you today in
the some of the major changes that we've
made is we removed the uh all of the
fees that were in the bill and we made
them into an appropriation
again I'm winging this here I don't have
the notes on this one exactly so my
apologies if I I Stumble a little bit
we uh we also added a lot of database
security into the build because there
was some issues with that and we added
in a doit position because we worked
with commissioner Jasper and with
commissioner Goulet from doit and we
found that there was a real need for a
doit position inside of the uh
the agricultural Department not only for
this bill but other areas where they're
already working they were they were
really short so we decided we would just
address it completely in this bill and
put one full-time person in I'll let the
commissioner speak more to them but I
believe if my memory serves me correctly
they had like one twentieth of one
person
dedicated to uh to doing their doit work
which translates to roughly two hours a
week and they they were falling short in
that area as well
so we have we did add that in sort of a
little bit of the background on this not
to take up too much of your time but in
the 2019 budget there were some changes
that were made in requirements for
becoming a pet vendors and registering
as a pet vendor excuse me the threshold
was was cut right in half and it swept
in a whole group of other people that
are breeders that were transferring
animals and that hadn't originally had
to register as they've had done there
so when the department was asked to
manage this they were doing it by
tracking Health certificates and the
commissioner again can speak to that but
they we received testimony in DNA that
they were receiving somewhere I mean it
was an astronomical number 60 or 80 000
of these certificates a year that they
were trying to manage and track and they
were all coming in in paper form they
still are
and so uh what this database will do
will is it will move them up to the 21st
century and allow them to the
veterinarians to directly enter that
information and into the database and
therefore the department will not have
to try and they figure out how to manage
these um and again the commissioner can
speak to what they've been doing they've
set up some type of a Excel spreadsheet
or something of that form that they've
been trying to re-enter these
certificates in and it's very
problematic and basically they can't do
their job they can't do what was
mandated of them so
we in in a nutshell we brought this back
down we narrowed it down to just Health
certificates uh there is some areas
within the uh build that are dealing
with using monies for other dedicated
funds which is why it's in front of you
for the initial setup but the funding of
the of the bill itself will come from uh
the appropriation that we've put in
I think I'm going to stop there because
I've covered most all of it and I don't
want to Ramble On too far and I'll open
up for questions and answer what I can
and again the some of the technical
questions about uh part of it you may
want to throw to the commissioner as
well so with that I'll I'll be happy to
answer any questions that I'm able to
thank you representative Pearl uh
questions from the committee
representative Bromley followed by
representative Elmer
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative Pearl uh
I'm looking at the fiscal note and uh I
have a sinking feeling that the fiscal
note
was before the bill was amended uh one
thing it says is that there's a two
dollar fee
the bill establishes a two dollar fee on
the submission of animal health
certificates
is that fee gone
yes it is in my apologies that was one
other point that I meant to uh to
mention the the fiscal note was on the
original bill it was not updated I had
spoken with Dave alaconis about updating
this fiscal note when it was in our
committee and he informed me that he was
not able to do that until it passed the
house floor I was under the assumption
that when it came to you as a second
committee bill that that would have been
done but I see it was not again my
apologies I'm not mentioning that that
was part of my notes I guess I skipped
over quickly here
oh and uh it does it does talk about
uh transfer of funds there's a certain
like the product scale testing fund
and let's stay with that one for
instance so that's still in place in the
bill
uh there's still going to be transfer
funds from certain dedicated funds is
that correct
that is correct I I would uh defer you
to the commissioner to give you some
real details on that as he is much more
versed on those individual funds than I
am
just just for the record uh members who
were here last year uh we spent a lot of
time on this bill as well so I was
someone familiar with it
is much appreciated we when we adopted
the language we used these suggestions
that were made last year in the Ways and
Means Committee so we appreciate that
work
okay thank you okay representative
thank you Mr chairman
um I I
also spent a lot of time working on this
last year and on the new version of this
which takes out the fees on then makes
no way as far as I can tell to reimburse
the the two funds that are being rated
from and we determined last term that uh
the Agricultural Product and scale
testing which is actually mostly animal
feed uh sales uh that that one is
receiving in more money than it really
needs and is built up quite a surplus
that could be used but it wasn't enough
for the objective which was to to create
the on the software
for this new uh database
and so they added in the integrated Pest
Management fund which on only had a
surplus because they had been without an
integrated Pest Management staffer for I
forget a couple of years at least an
integrated test management is really
important to agriculture
and um in this state
and on
the idea at the time was that if on
those new fees came in enough they would
completely reimburse the integrated Pest
Management fund and then uh as much as
they could in within two years after
which it would just stabilize on they
would reimburse the animal feed
on program
which on oversees on all of our pet food
mostly but also animal food for for
Farmers on and make sure that people
aren't being soldings that are uh
dangerous
so
um that's my brief version of it so my
question is have you discussed
how what is going to happen to the
integrated Pest Management program of
New Hampshire
um
with no extra money coming in and those
two funds being on what we call when
we're not being polite rated
thank you thank you representative I
appreciate you filling in some of the uh
the background in the blanks I I was
trying to keep it brief I again I'm
going to defer a lot of the technical
parts of that to the commissioner
because he has done a lot of work on on
those funds and what the sustainability
of them and what their ability is to uh
have some funds withdrawn from them I
will add this um the committee looked at
the fee portion of this bill for a long
time and have a good amount of
discussion about it and we really felt
that the legislature had had enacted
this um this requirement on the
department back in the 2019 budget and
we didn't feel that it was fair to put
that onto the backs of all of the animal
owners of the State of New Hampshire
through the fees on rabies certificates
and health transfers by putting a two
dollar fee on the rabies certificates
you virtually are affecting every animal
owner in the state of New Hampshire and
we just did not feel that was fair and
it was good policy for for New Hampshire
animal Agriculture and for the pet
owners and so we uh we stripped that out
of it and uh I guess you can use the
word rated I'm fine with that
we still feel that those funds are being
used within the uh within the
agricultural community and so we didn't
have a as big of an issue but I do
understand there was a concern with the
IPM and I know that commissioner Jasper
has a lot of information nation that he
can share on that so I'll defer the
details to him
also representative
yes for the moment
okay there's no other hands up
[Music]
commissioner Jasper
good morning for the record I am
commissioner Sean Jasper the New
Hampshire Department of Agriculture
markets and food and it's always a
pleasure to be before my uh
formal former committee
um
that I was a member of for several terms
in my former life as a state
representative
there are a lot of questions out there
it might be more productive but I leave
that to you
for us to just fill in the blanks and
talk about this through the questions
rather than me
um rambling on which I'm always happy to
do anyhow but um
you might prefer to to get to the points
by asking
um questions I could of course respond
to some of Representative almie's
uh did you want to respond to any of her
comments sure so
while you know frankly I am a a
proponent of of fees for user fees which
this primarily
um would have been uh the house decided
to to take that out which complicates
things and so there is a 250 000
appropriation
um within the bill to to fund the
ongoing maintenance
uh now what is not appropriate at this
point we are expecting a updated fiscal
note from uh commissioner Goulet as to
the cost of the new position that is
also not in the bill and so the that'll
be somewhere in the vicinity of of a
hundred thousand dollars so the total
cost without the fee to the general fund
would be about three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
uh annually in terms of the funds right
from the beginning
um I I recognize that it was probably
going to be
pretty much impossible to get a million
dollar appropriation which is our
estimate working with various vendors of
what it might cost to actually develop
this program and so between that and the
fee I was trying to make this uh whole
program neutral to the general fund that
was before we really realized that it
was going to be necessary to have an I.T
person as well
so the
um
product and scale testing fund which is
somewhat
misnamed because it really has nothing
to do with scale testing for some reason
money was coming out of here related to
weights and measures in the scale
testing but no Revenue comes into it
from that so this is really all just
money that comes in from animal products
animal foods and treats and anything
that an animal might
consume
so that fund is estimated
um in
in this next year to peek out at a
balance of about 1.7 million dollars you
know of course that's an estimate right
now we we closed out fiscal year 20 with
about a million and a half left in in
the fund
due to the covet pandemic and the
governor's orders to uh reduce our
budgets we've pulled more out of this
budget
uh to avoid layoffs in the department
and so with that taken into
consideration
um
at the end of fiscal year 23 we're
anticipating a balance of their in that
fund of still about nine hundred
thousand dollars
um now
and I will will tell you that since the
governor last week
opened the budget up a little bit
because of the revenues and increasing
I'm probably going to seek permission to
get some of the money back in these two
funds that we have budgeted for ongoing
operations because neither of these
funds will be sustainable if this
becomes the way we try to fund the the
department
um so obviously going from you know a
million and a half and twenty to nine
hundred thousand dollars
in um in 23 without taking any money out
for this program makes this fund
non-sustainable as to the pesticides
fund
uh we closed out
fiscal year 20 with just over 2 million
in it
um and we're looking to to budget about
three quarters of a million dollars out
of that between the normal programs that
we do
and we've asked and the governor did
include it in hospital too a provision
to allow us to fund the division uh part
of the division from that fund so that
three quarters of a million dollars
of expenditure compares to about five
five hundred thousand dollars of income
so again is not sustainable at that
level long term but this was a stop Gap
measure
um we're we're projecting that with that
without anything to do with the database
we ended up about a million and a half
left in the fund at the close of fiscal
year 23. so drawing that down for
budgetary purposes by by about a half a
million dollars so between the two funds
we're projecting
that we would close out fiscal year 23
with just about two million dollars in
the fund which leaves us plenty of money
between the two funds to uh to fund this
database
and so I'll stop there and you really
worked hard in trying to accomplish this
well it's we're not doing the job that
the legislature has has mandated us to
do
um and the only way to do it is with a
database so as representative Pearl said
uh we're doing everything manually but
what he didn't tell you is there's about
000 Health certificates that are issued
in the state a year
we don't receive anywhere near 80 000
here because we have no way to file them
we have no way even if we got them we
don't have enough room to have filing
cabinets to put those 80 000 documents
in a year
so primarily some veterinarians just
send them in
but most of the ones we get is are the
ones that we request because we suspect
there may be people who are operating as
pet vendors without a license or where
you know something related to that and
we request from in one case we looked at
a a range
um of veterinarians within uh
the the location of the person we
suspected was a pet vendor and requested
the records from all of those
veterinarians and in some cases we had
to request them several times because we
suspect some you know didn't want to be
seen as ratting out if you will on their
client
uh so it's very time consuming and then
we had to sort through all of those and
having a database would allow us to to
do those type of searches with a push of
the button
and be able to comply with what the
state
uh would do
um being in the you know dealing with
pet vending is not something the
Department of Agriculture really wants
to be doing but it's what you've told us
you want us to do and so we need to do
it the best we can and this is
this is the only way that we can even
come close to doing what you've asked us
to do thank you commissioner
representative Bromley I have a question
commissioner uh always good to see you
good to see you so um so the two funds
agriculture product fund and the
integrated Pest Management fund
I just want to make sure I'm clear on
this are going to be used to fund
the development of the software is that
correct that is that is correct because
currently they're both carrying a
balance higher than anything we we could
possibly anticipate needing that that
balance or
and follow-up would be uh and then
instead of asking for a two dollar fee
for rabies vaccinations or whatever
you've now chosen a 350
000 annual appropriation
to maintain the database well we haven't
asked for that um that was not something
we were proponents of that was what the
environment AG committee decided to do
they didn't want want the fee that's the
legislative prerogative my job was to
come up with a way to fund this uh they
also didn't feel that it was necessary
to have the rabies uh certificates
included in this uh and that's that's
fine it does make the program a little
bit simpler we just felt that at the
time that was probably something that uh
was a good thing to do but it's not
necessary for our our mission
would have helped Town clerks and police
departments but really not the
Department of Agriculture so while this
probably doesn't change the maintenance
fee if there were a fee in here just on
the health certificates
which we're changing to certificates of
transfer
we would probably be looking at a a fee
of
for the total cost to make this Revenue
neutral probably be in the vicinity of
four dollars and fifty cents
um or so to make it totally Revenue
neutral
um and that needs to be weighed against
the fact that you know when you're
looking at transfers particularly of
dogs you can be looking at cost of about
two thousand dollars a dog I mean
obviously some are much less than that
but you're still talking hundreds the
veterinary examination is not going to
be cheap so you know our particular
feeling is that
um a fee of you know four dollars and
fifty cents or five dollars a transfer
certificate is um
very reasonable and not a not a burden
but that's not our call that that is
the legislature's call to make I just
wanted to put it into perspective for
you uh follow up Mr chair
okay so this is something that you're
proposing here it's not in the bill
uh the uh
uh agriculture committee didn't
recommend us
uh but this is you're saying that if if
we did not want a general fund
appropriation this is for the ongoing
this is for the ongoing money yes
if we don't want to go to the to the
general fund to get money
to maintain this these programs
that a 4.50
uh fee on health certificates is one
option that we we could consider is that
that's what I'm hearing is that correct
that's our our best estimate in in that
in with the fact that we actually don't
know how many Health certificates are
currently being issued because we don't
receive them all right our best estimate
is the um
eight eighty thousand a year
and so if you do the the math based on
on that
um you know come close to 450 to to
cover the total expenses Mr chair I have
one more just one more now one more
follow-up
um so the two funds the agriculture
product fund and the integrated Pest
Management fund
refresh refresh our memories as to on
the normal times or currently current
times
where does that money go who is it just
wind up in your general budget no uh how
is that how are those dollars spent now
sure so
the um
the product and scale testing fund is a
is a fund that
um we are you free to use
however we want based on on the budget
so we have been budgeting
all our of our vehicles through that
fund we have been
budgeting the director of weights and
measures and other uh at least another
position there so in normal times we
have been spending
around
you know probably on average about 400
uh to 500 000 in that and it's been
bringing in about five hundred thousand
dollars
of Revenue it has been growing slightly
um
in that and that varies so what I've
done in this current budget is have it
more aligned more accurately now for
savings and looking at our Fleet we've
decided to forego buying
um
new cars we may have one or two in there
this time but primarily focusing on
using that to avoid layoffs so we've
moved that up to um total expenditure of
000 versus a revenue of
five hundred thousand dollars in in
round round numbers so that's why not
sustainable that's why I I'm hoping to
talk to the other representative Ober
who is the uh division chairman for my
budget uh to see if we can at least do
something in the second year because I
think as you all know it's going to be
harder to get a lot of money back going
forward and
um I don't want to put these funds in
danger as terms of the pesticide fund
um the purpose of that is for uh has
been for programming
in Grants
nowhere near enough of the those grants
have been coming in so we've been
getting about again about half half a
million dollars into that fund and let
me back up a minute so on the
uh
fund relative to the uh
um product and scale testing fund that's
a 50 50 split between
um general fund and the uh
in our in our fund so 50 of what we
collect goes into the general fund 50
stays here in the pesticide fund it's 75
of what we collect goes to the state
general fund and 25 goes into this this
fund so we've been collecting about a
half a million dollars we've been
spending
uh roughly a quarter of a million
dollars a year so that fund has been
building up rather rapidly and I do
think it makes a great deal of sense to
be funding other positions
um from from this fund uh the fee has
not gone up it
in either of these areas the fees have
not gone up in uh in decades
um and so we're we're quite reasonable
and actually lower than than many other
states in both of these areas but we are
budgeting out of uh the pesticide fund
three quarters of a million dollars
versus the
um
the half a million of
so again pulling down these funds
neither are sustainable
um
regardless of what we do with the
with the database at the current level I
can't sustain the funds but it was a way
to make sure we didn't lay off employees
and particularly in the air pesticides
that would be a huge mistake to lay
people off because we need to have good
regulations of pesticides and those who
are who are applying those those
pesticides to our um
to fields and homes and Orchards and
everywhere so
I hope that answers your question thank
you commissioner a lot of us have chats
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman
on commissioner you had last time said
that the IPM fund was supposed to have a
staffer who worked with integrated Pest
Management that's what it's called
that's what it's supposed to do
uh and now you're telling us that
that um it's basically feeding the
general fund
and that there's not enough money for
either a staffer or the grants that were
being done no I I'm sorry
no I I apologize if I if I let you to
that conclusion that's 700
um
roughly seven seven hundred fifty
thousand does include that staffer that
was currently authorized plus I believe
two more plus all of the grants that we
anticipate being so it's all related to
the any expenditures would actually be
related to the programs and the uh in
the operation of
uh of pesticides so nothing other than
what we might be taking out for
um for the the database everything else
that's coming out of there is directly
except for the three quarters of it that
goes to the general fund yeah that's and
that's always been the way so if you
look at the department as a whole
um now the governor did approve our our
priorities
so with these funds with everything else
we do the Department of Agriculture is
almost Revenue neutral without the
set-asides we we the department is
revenue positive to the general fund by
a hundred thousand but that does not
include
the um
million dollars roughly from uh
pesticides it goes to the general fund
anyhow and the 500 000 that goes to
um
from from the product scale testing so
that's an additional million and a half
so our whole operation is very much net
so excuse me but what that means is that
agriculture which a lot of people think
is important to this state on and which
is uh
in a worse economic position than of
most of the industry in this state is
paying money into the general fund
uh
on a net basis correct
and things like making sure that there
isn't pesticide that's going to kill us
on our apples uh
is underfunded
well I I wouldn't say
I mean under we don't have any
additional requests but had we not gone
this route we would have to lay off
people in in the department that is that
is correct we were not given
um enough appropriation within the
governor's
um
budget to fully fund all our positions
so I had to raid raid the funds and seek
authorization which was has been granted
I understand on if your agency has been
a step child in the budget process for a
very long time first at least as long as
I've been around
so on I did want to ask some other
questions though on if I may go ahead Mr
chairman thank you on there are I
understand that was I hadn't noticed
what that was put in by the environment
and agriculture committee there is an
appropriation which is only for the
maintenance of the database once it is
set up uh and your estimate is that the
debate database is going to cost about a
million dollars to set it up and that's
what it was last term too on and I
understand that if we keep this uh
requirement for
um on using the health certificates I
believe it was mostly on
part of an initiative to make sure that
there wouldn't be on a lot of unhealthy
animals
on traded in the state
but on
that as long as that initiative is there
that it is pretty much impossible for
you to carry out the job without the
database
on but there's an appropriate that
appropriation for 250
000 Plus
uh
a hundred thousand for a technical new
technical person in doit is something
that has to be considered in the budget
itself
by the finance committee and ended up
because there were originally fees in it
with the bill which is only in our
possession at this point it can't go to
finance officially and I would like to
ask our chairman uh what we're going to
we're still here I'll get a hold of Ken
and discuss this with them
yeah and and went over because she's in
charge of division one which was my
division when I was on finance we did a
lot of Agriculture work
is the chairman of Lynn is the vice
are you also being honest
yes uh can you hear me yes uh good
morning commissioner good to see you
you're looking very Dapper Dan today
and uh let me uh Begin by saying that I
love animals I had a Britney spaniel uh
hunting dog that I went out into the
woods with for over 20 years in my
younger days
and uh so I really want to emphasize
that I do love animals
number two you mentioned a commissioner
that you were thinking about a cost of
four to five four to four dollars and
fifty cents and I would uh personally
feel that it would not be
uh detrimental to me as a hunter uh to
be charged the the fee of five dollars
as much uh in order to get the
certificate uh is that anathema
to tell just the hunter or the just the
people that have animals that they're
going to have to pay a five dollar
certificate would that kill that bill I
think he talked about the fourth
district
in order to be able to keep this
self-supporting because feed has been
removed by the agricultural committee so
we're not talking about the fee right
now
I thought the fee of two dollars was
mentioned that it's been withdrawn yes
and there's there's no new fee that
we're considering at this point in time
all right so my my point is that if I
were to write a bill to say that you got
to pay five dollars if you're an animal
owner would that be appropriate at this
time to ask the commissioner if that
this time it wouldn't be considered
until next year
thank you representative Elliott one of
the things and
um my words were sort of used against me
on on the floor speech
um on this bill because what I said was
that I'm I'm really not worried about
getting into the details of this bill at
that at this point because it's going to
take a couple years to develop this
database
so
what's really the only thing that's
important to me right now
uh is to be able to begin the
development and have the authorization
to develop it so if the legislature were
to rethink the idea of
um having a fee that could be done
anytime within the next two years the
appropriation that we're looking for for
the I.T uh person while that position
might be appropriate
to have on board as this this is
developed we won't need the 250 000
at very least
um it very soonest until the second year
of the biennium probably not even then
but if we don't have the you know if
we're not honest about this moving
forward it's going to be very difficult
to uh
to come back and say oh yeah by the way
we need 250 000. so what we're really
looking for is the 250 000 and the
second second year of the biennium
probably
uh if we're lucky some of that will be
needed in the second year but probably
not a full Year's maintenances
um we have a database that is being
developed
to replace one that was created by
prisoners
and um
that contract was signed with dlit
before I became commissioner and if
we're lucky we'll be going live with
that weights and measures program this
year and I've been commissioner now for
for three years so I not really thinking
we're gonna gonna get this going too
quickly because even if it's approved
July 1st we'll have to go out to bid
um probably won't be awarding a contract
earlier than the end of the year and
then
you know that only leaves a year and a
half for development within this
biennium so any other changes as I I've
said
not really concerned about right now the
bill Works mechanically
but I recognize that people may have
some other other ideas on how to fund it
or what should be in it what shouldn't
be plenty of time to discuss that um
in another year
thank you representative Pearl
foreign
thank you Mr chairman I I just wanted to
add that I've had extensive
conversations with the finance uh chair
Weiler about this bill and he is
understanding of what it requires and
what it would need to uh to be in the
budget so I just wanted to give some
Assurance to the committee that Finance
is well aware of this they're well aware
of the 250 000 appropriation and that we
were looking for uh a doit position my
estimate to uh chairman Weiler was
around 350 000 would need to be in the
budget and he has um mentioned to me
that he would uh when the time is right
he would like me to draft up a couple of
amendments adding that into house bill
2. so just so the committee is aware
thank you great information about that
Pearl
uh representative the model
it was a hand but it's gone so
anybody else wish to comment or a
question
anybody else
yeah uh this is for you Mr chair so to
me it looks like the the only issues
that are before us
are addressing whether or not
uh the uh agriculture product fund and
the integrated Pest Management fund
some of those fees can be used for the
development of the software
am I missing something or is that
correct is that a correct statement
without destroying a little fund right
but this is something that will be be
discussing I'm sure yes okay the
representative tell me
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to ask
the commissioner to provide a written
version of the statement he made early
on about on all of where all the money
funds are on amounts are going and
coming from in those two funds on I
don't believe when the dedicated fund
committee looked at agriculture I can't
remember which year it was that on we
learned that we knew that on the animal
products fund was essentially a general
fund of the department for instance
so um
it's um I think it's very pertinent to
this whether there is enough money there
or can be put enough money there with
the help of Finance which we need to
collaborate with on those amendments
um
to make this work Sorry my phone's going
off
I'll be glad to um email to the entire
committee the
the budget for those two funds
if that would be appropriate Mr chairman
and then if anyone has any questions
about the details
um
I'll be glad to respond to uh to any
questions via email as soon as you could
that would be great yeah we have that
information I'll talk to my
administrative assistant and try to get
that out this morning
any further questions to ask of
Representative Pearl or the commissioner
major
one
of these that has their hand raised
who has their
[Music]
name
okay that's
start ending in 613 could they identify
themselves
allow them to talk yes star six oh yeah
thank you thank you good morning can you
hear me clearly
yes yes
okay
um I am actually a member of the public
so I don't know if it's appropriate for
me to speak right now
I was raising my hand to be able to
testify when appropriate
are you testifying for or against uh
I am testifying against
would you identify Who You Are
uh yes if it's appropriate for me to
speak right now I'll go ahead and
continue uh and discuss uh
what I've heard so far and my concerns
about this bill my name is Lisa Marie
mulkern been a resident of New Hampshire
I'm sorry hold on one second uh yes
everybody else
questions for replica representing Pearl
sin No Hands then continue
okay thank you uh Mr chair members of
the committee I appreciate the
opportunity this morning to speak an
adamant opposition to this bill
my name is Lisa Marie mulkern I've been
a resident of New Hampshire and a tax
paying citizen nearly my all of my adult
life I am very familiar with the history
of this database and I have
um several concerns and questions I was
not able to testify at the first
committee but I did listen to the
testimony that was provided there
uh what I have done and um I'll save you
the time-consuming uh you know my
background why I'm entitled to speak if
you have questions about my background
after I'm finished raising my concerns I
would invite questions about it or you
can simply do an internet search for my
name Lisa Marie mulkarn
okay
um I went to the um what I'm concerned
about now it sounds as if uh hearing
from the commissioner uh who has had um
prisoners work on the database for
weights and means which is very
concerning to me when I look at the
audit report from 2017 that was done on
the department and the significant
deficiencies that were noted by the
Auditors about how various fees and
funds are reconciled there in the
department
there were very concerning um
deficiencies particularly regarding the
animal population control fund as an
example a random sample of you know 40
nearly 44 samples of those applications
for funding for the spay neuter program
there in New Hampshire
um 20 of them indicated that they didn't
qualify so nearly half of the people
sampled didn't even qualify so they were
not even financially qualified to
receive the low-cost spay neuter
assistance
yet they they got it and then the
personally identifiable information on
all of those applications which includes
Social Security numbers drivers licenses
bank statements anything that you would
have to submit to prove neediness
were found to be uh subject to anyone
obtaining that information so there was
significant identity theft opportunities
there in in in that case and now I'm
hearing from the commissioner well you
know let's not add the five dollar fee
to the pet to pet owners that's what
really you know killed it in the last
Committee just give me the money for the
database let's get that going I need
that appropriation no we also have
significant deficiencies in um our
administrative rules listed in that
audit report
and as far back as I believe it was 2012
or 2013
when the state veterinarian under the
Department of Agriculture moved to have
this quarantine
48-hour quarantine put in place for the
animals that were coming through
New Hampshire
I asked I I volunteered my time
specifically I wanted to know what was
really the threat where was the threat
were there complaints being made where
these animals really causing harm where
their communicable diseases and not and
and I pulled a foia request out of the
department and there was nothing to
substantiate that quarantining back in
2012-2013.
then in 2015
Senate Bill 505 was offered to correct
some of the significant deficiencies in
RSA 437 to include simple things like
defining a licensed veterinarian
to allow people in New Hampshire to
engage in interstate commerce
as they're entitled to under the rights
of the Constitution to obtain their pets
from any location any state and to
ensure its Health by allowing the state
veterinarian to accept an out-of-state
health certificate
but no
that didn't happen that bill got killed
as well
and now you're telling me you need a
million dollars for a database a million
dollars for a database
the world's leading Pro computer
programmers
are funded grants of a hundred thousand
dollars a year from the leading ventral
capitalists in this country
to develop application software
that does far more than some random
database for 80 000 Health certificates
where is that number coming from
in this fiscal note it says it's coming
from some random random uh you know uh
data from some avma report or something
really I want to know where they're
coming from in the state of New
Hampshire I want to know how this money
is going to be managed what what the
processes are going to be put in place
this bill needs to be euthanized
immediately
well thank you for your testimony any
I say no no questions in the committee
anybody else want to testify for or
against
representative major there's a Stacy
representing
I mean commissioner Jasper did you want
to make a comment
yes thank you
I would encourage you to to go back and
look at the audit report which I have
just done
um and there are many inaccuracies in in
what you you heard
the
um issue of course these were all things
the audit was performed before I became
commissioner
the um
the database that I refer to the weights
and measures
developed that was something that was
done I think in the 70s and the 80s by
the state of New Hampshire it was not at
the request of the Department of
Agriculture to have databases
constructed by the uh by prisoners I as
soon as I learned that I thought that
was a horrific idea
the numbers that we came up with for the
database were done through conversations
with three different uh vendors
particularly some who are already
working with um with Vital Records out
of the Secretary of State's office
because to to some degree it's a similar
system so those are not numbers that
came from some random organization they
came from meetings with vendors who are
interested in bidding on them and giving
us their best estimate
and but certainly even the the audit
does not I'm not sure what this has to
do with any of this
but
um the identified
20 instances where the support of the
applications eligibility did not meet
the administrative rule criteria
that's far different from saying they
did they were not eligible there just
was a lack of documentation
uh put in there so I I think you know
you can judge testimony based on the
accuracy of information that is given to
you and um I would I would leave it at
that but the audit you can get a copy of
I'm from the LBA and we are working on
all of the things that
that were identified as
areas of concerns in in the audit
and I'll leave it there thank you thank
you commissioner okay um
Stacy Ober has her hands up from the
yes good morning thank you for this
opportunity to speak in support of
amended house 532 the animal records
database my name is Stacy Ober I Am The
Advocate in New England for the American
Kennel Club and can speak to you and
express appreciation to all the work
that the house environment and
agriculture committee did in
collaboration with commissioner Jasper
we had brought forward with the New
Hampshire dog owners of the Granite
State Angela Ferrari had signed up to
testify but had a work obligation at 10
o'clock so I'm just jumping in uh to
speak on behalf of both AKC and New
Hampshire dogs with regard to the
removal of the rabies vaccination fee
and also the removal of the fee for
electronic health record transfers
um just by way of quick background and
why we support an appropriation to
maintain the database is that those fees
in the original proposal would have
disproportionately impacted dog owners
um when the Senate included
this expansion of the pet vendor license
that the Department of Agriculture
issues back in 2019 the Senate included
this language in the Senate budget and
there was no change to the requirement
of dog owners to obtain dog licenses
from their municipality which is an
enforcement mechanism for the rabies
vaccination dog owners pay for those dog
licenses and they also are required to
contribute money that goes into the
animal population fund that the state
maintains for spay neuter Services when
the animal records database was
originally conceptualized the fee would
be on dog owners again for rabies
vaccinations to now fund enamel records
database and also for health certificate
transfers
the dog owners in New Hampshire feel as
though this is a disproportionate fee
being placed on them because arguably
when you look look at the scope of the
animal records database it includes cat
owners ferret owners and by virtue of
the broad Authority initially
included in the database we all
anticipated the Department of
Agriculture and entering the 21st
century would also be utilizing the
database for instance in monitoring
livestock and other health records of
other animals and therefore
um we were grateful to the environment
and AG committee for understanding uh
that dog owners are already paying these
fees this would be a duplication of fees
and uh that it would be more appropriate
to yes incrementally establish the
database with an understanding that it
will bring the department into the 21st
century in a way that it can actually
provide for all animals domestic and
livestock you know in in the state of
thank you for your testimony uh Mrs
olber
saying no questions from committee
anybody else wish to testify for or
saying none I'm closing the public
hearing on House Bill 532.
foreign
just take a two minute break and we'll
okay
foreign
are we all set Janine
we're ready uh representative Hunt is
not here
whoa
okay I'm going to open the public
hearing on House Bill 610--fm
an act requiring certain licensing and
Reporting functions to be conducted
through the Nationwide multi-state
licensing system and registry
and relative to the background
investigation of trust offices to a
certain filing fees assessments and
interest rates into the transmission of
consumer complaints by the banking
Department
and so the representative is not here I
have the testifying sheep and as one
to speak and support
and there's one two three five people
signed up in support
that one person is sorry your uncle
Mr chairman yes
would you like me to introduce the bill
thank you
uh representative Susan elmy uh city of
Lebanon Grafton 13. I'm introducing
House Bill 610 FN requiring certain
licensing and Reporting functions be
conducted through the Nationwide
multi-state licensing system and
registry and relating to background
investigations of trust officers to
certain filing fees assessments and
interest rates and to the transmission
of consumer complaints by the banking
department and in the absence of
Representative hunt I am taking no
questions thank you
okay
okay thank you representative only
and now we'll go to the
hi my name is Kiara dolcino I'm the
general counsel at the New Hampshire
banking Department
this bill is at the request of the
banking Department it accomplishes a
number of important changes to our laws
none of the changes will have an overall
fiscal impact due to the manner in which
the department is funded
any additional revenue or any cost
savings only operates to reduce or
affect the assessment that is imposed on
our chartered and licensed institutions
so the overall effect of the bill any
fiscal impact is really uh does not
affect the bottom line
I've submitted some written testimony
which I hope is helpful I can go through
the bill quickly to explain how the bill
makes changes to our laws
um and then I'm happy to answer any
questions okay if you could briefly go
through the bill
sure so sections one through fifteen
we're only concentrating on the part
that deals with the revenue okay
understood
okay so
um sections one through 15 really have
no physical impact
um they're just requiring licensees to
register excuse me license and Report
through the nmls system so I won't
discuss that any further
sections 16 through 19 do impose some
additional fiscal cost on our trust
companies these changes arose through
the Senate Bill 98 study committee and
would now require that any new directors
that are appointed to a Trust Company
undergo a background investigation and
bear the cost of that background
investigation
uh section 20 of the bill also has
fiscal impact again this was a provision
that came out of the Senate Bill 98
study committee it would increase the
fee for applications for new Charters
new Banks trust companies or credit
unions from ten thousand dollars to
fifteen thousand dollars
what we were finding were that certain
applications were taking significant
amounts of time
um and so we felt it was appropriate to
have the applicant bear that cost rather
than shift that cost to all institutions
uh who would pick up the the difference
uh section 21 of the bill does not
really have a fiscal impact it was just
to clarify that institutions have to pay
their required assessment even if they
dissolve um during the the course of the
fiscal year
section 22
um has modest fiscal impact and that it
it would
um eliminate the need of the department
to calculate the interest rate for
escrow funds that are escrowed for
purposes of mortgages and paying taxes
and insurance
that ties it to the federal funds rate
and we believe that will help reduce
staff time at the department
sections finally sections 23 to 28 also
have some cost Savings in that we are
requesting the ability to transmit
consumer complaints via email rather
than certified mail and there will be
I'm happy to answer any questions uh
regarding any of the bill well thank you
for your testimony questions from the
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony as you're speaking
I had a flashback was this bill did we
deal with this bill last year and it
didn't make it through the Senate yes
sir that's correct it did actually make
it through the Senate some of the
provisions were will be familiar because
a number of bills did a pass both the
house and the Senate unfortunately the
bill was included in the Omnibus bills
that went to the governor and uh was all
this the bills were ultimately vetoed
that that that's helpful so the big
change really is the uh
on page six line 36
the 10 000 going to the fifteen thousand
correct oh and I did I'm sorry I did uh
forget to mention
um the bill would also allow the
commissioner to charge additional uh
charges
um if in reviewing an application
um the even the fifteen thousand dollars
wasn't sufficient to cover the
Department's time
um and so that provision again was
something that you saw last year in HB
1696 uh again it passed the House and
Senate and it's before you again
exactly the same as last year there's a
slight change that was requested by the
chartered institutions
um just some additional language so that
they would have
um to discuss the notice they would
receive if the department determined
that their application was going to
exceed the fifteen thousand dollar
threshold and we need to charge
additional funds
um but it just added some notice a
provision to let them know that was
going to occur and to give them the
opportunity to withdraw the application
at that time do you remember what the
vote was coming out of the
Commerce committed
I believe it it was
um a park I believe there were two
Representatives who voted
um uh against the bill I believe it was
representative Sanborn and
representative Warden I'm not entirely
sure but I'm sure it's in the record but
otherwise it did pass okay
I I checked
Mr chair yes I have it there was I had a
committee it came out 19 to nothing this
year's bill
oh I'm sorry I thought you meant last
year right so last year it was that vote
but this year I had I checked it was 19.
yes and it was I think it was probably
on consent calendar because it was a
Voice vote Yes right can I have one
follow-up if I know there's others who
wanted to speak but
um
so it looks like you read instead of
using ABCD we went to uh parentheses one
two three four I just want to make sure
the committee understands that all these
other fees were already in existence
can you just verify that
you there I'm sorry um can you uh I mean
looking at the bill now which sections
are you referring to go to page six
uh down the bottom line start with 36
yes oh yes in in that for yes those
those fees are all existing fees correct
yes you just read numbered it was just
the renumbering that correct okay
that's all I have thank you
uh represent Almy followed by
representative spilsbury
thank you on it's still Cino do you um
could you please explain for our newer
members the
um way that the department of banking is
funded and what it would mean that
certain uh members uh users of the bank
uh Department of banking on pay in if
they pay particular things in fees or
fines how that relates to the total
funding of the banking Department yes
certainly
um I um in my written testimony I
explained that the department collects
over the course of the year uh
application fees
um examination fees
um and then penalties and other costs
that are imposed and if there's a
deficiency between what we collect and
the charges the cost for running the
department then we impose an assessment
on our institutions
um to to collect those the deficiency so
at the end of the day we are self-funded
we collect all funds necessary to cover
the Department's costs if we collect
additional Revenue it would reduce the
assessment if we impose additional costs
it would reduce the assessment and if
there's a less a cost of the department
to do its business then the assessment
is reduced so in the end it's a zero sum
game there's no overall impact to the
bottom line only a difference in the
amount of the assessment imposed
thank you if I could just follow up for
a second
represent only go ahead just to make
that clear if I on a bank on
puts in on for work done by the
department which costs a lot more than
it does to anyone else on and there is
no way to pay for it in fees then all of
the banks will be paying for it correct
there's a cost shifting yes and we're
trying to address that in this bill by
charging the fees that we think are
necessary
so that that cost is not shifted to the
other institutions
thank you
representative Pillsbury
thank you Mr chairman I'm just curious
how for how long a time has the fee been
set at ten thousand
um that's a good question I'm not sure
um I can look at the bill and see when
the last amendment was in place but I
believe it hasn't changed since at least
2015.
I
Bernstein did you have your hand up
representative I did but my question was
just asked okay uh representative Bronte
uh my recollection from last year was
that
it was more than just a ten thousand it
seemed like it was ten thousand
you're assessing a new bank or a new
Credit Union
to initially pay ten thousand but if
your work took you beyond that ten
thousand that you would assess another
ten thousand is that correct
yeah well there is a provision that says
if the if the new fee the fifteen
thousand dollars doesn't cover the cost
of the department staff and reviewing
the application then the commissioner
will notify the institution or the
applicant explain that it appears that
the applicant has exceeded the fifteen
thousand dollars
fee and that we will need to start
charging additional cost what we find is
sometimes we have applicants who come to
the department who are not really
prepared in submitting the application
and you know we do a lot of work
reviewing it and they have to come back
to us with multiple
um business plans or multiple revisions
um and so you know those kinds of
applications take a lot of time and a
lot of effort on the book Department's
end so the bill would permit the
commissioner to notify the applicant
that they are now exceeding the fifteen
thousand dollar fee and that we would
have to start charging them additional
costs and then at that point they would
have the ability to either withdraw
their application or continue
with that can I do a follow-up so with
that continuation be a time of materials
kind of a charge
um we would if you're asking how we
would impose the charge we would um it's
the based on the per diem exam fee
that's already in the law and the
department tracks the time spent on the
application and we would Bill based on
that per DM fee
one more follow-up is it is it my
understanding that that was kind of the
practice with the 10 000 as well no the
additional charges is a new provision
that came out of the Senate Bill 98
study committee okay thank you
questions from the
tests and none rehab somebody from the
attendee
uh Lee oxenham could you let me
I think she might be on for the next
bill but maybe we should ask her for
Lee oxenham uh you making a comment on
do you have a comment for House Bill 610
.
all right then anybody else have
questions or comments on House Bill 610.
we have nobody signed up in a position
only signed up in support and only one
signed up to testify and we just heard
from us
I'm going to close the public hearing on
I'm going to open the public hearing on
House Bill 614--fm
an act exempting the state and political
subdivision from payment of the cost of
compliance with a renewable portfolio
standard
okay
Michael wants here
I just
promoted him to panelists
good
representative Michael Voss
we want to introduce your bill
and thank you remember that
the policy has been voted by the science
technology energy committee and we're
only
listening to Pops that would affect
revenues representative Ross
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
honorable colleagues thanks for letting
me uh introduce this bill to you this
morning
I sent you a written testimony
um yesterday or the day before I can't
remember exactly when
um so you should have that in your inbox
that'll give you the basics on what this
bill does
I'm going to skip directly to attachment
one in my written testimony which is the
estimate of the financial impact of this
bill
so
there's a spreadsheet there that shows
the last five years of data about the
state of New Hampshire's
um electricity usage
and you will notice that uh
the state has used about 76 to 77
million kilowatt hours of electricity
every year from 2016 to 2019 those
numbers came from The Office of the
State energy manager
the 2020 number which is considerably
higher at 105 million kilowatts actually
came from the Public Utilities
Commission and their data was part of
the spreadsheet that they used or the
worksheet that they used to come up with
the
Financial note for the bill
there is a discrepancy between those
numbers but I was not able to get an
explanation of that discrepancy
nevertheless using those numbers
like estimated the amount of money that
the state of New Hampshire would save by
not paying the renewable portfolio
standard and as you'll see under the
column labeled RPS
over the last five years the state would
have received some would have saved
somewhere between 356
000 to 508 thousand dollars per year
by not paying the RPS
just as a tangential tangential note the
state would have saved even more by not
paying the system benefits charge
nevertheless the the average number for
the State over the last five years is
roughly four hundred thousand dollars
the total over the last five years is
almost two million dollars
so there are considerable savings to be
uh obtained by passing this bill just
for the State of New Hampshire
and by the way for the record I used the
number in the far right hand column that
is
.00482 that is the reconciled number
that eversource uses to uh compute
its costs for complying with the RPS per
kilowatt hour
now it is true that the state does not
buy its electricity from eversource or
Unitil or Liberty it contracts with a
competitive or alternative supplier to
get its energy
but those uh entities are not regulated
by the puc and they're not required to
Port report to the puc so I couldn't get
exact numbers from those entities about
the state or any individual towns
electricity costs so I estimated them
using that number from eversource which
came out of its latest race rate case
filing
if you go down a little farther on the
spreadsheet I also estimated the cost
savings for a couple of our larger
cities Manchester and Nashua which based
on their electricity expenditures in
2019 which is data that I got from their
Town websites
uh
Manchester could save somewhere around
173 thousand dollars Nashua could save
somewhere around 136 thousand dollars by
not paying the RPS and even my little
town of Epping could save somewhere
around nine thousand dollars by not
paying the RPS
so those are the financial financial
implications of
passing this bill I would just like to
point out one other point and that is
that there are five Municipal
electricity companies in the state that
are owned by a municipality Wolfeboro
Lancaster and three others in the North
country
and none of those Municipal
electricities require their customers to
pay the RPS or the SBC and they do that
to keep costs low for their uh
taxpayers who are also the rate payers
for the electricity in their towns so
it's a concept that has a precedent and
a concept that has been proven to work
and that's one of the reasons why I
introduced this bill
so with that I'll uh turn it over to you
guys to ask me questions and I'll do my
best to answer them thank you
thank you Mr chairman on I would have
appreciated it if we could have had
those numbers up on the screen since
yesterday was town meeting day and some
of us were way too busy to be able to
try and find this email but
um I would like to ask what you are
trying to do is to do away with the
renewable portfolio standard why didn't
you just kill it
what is going to happen if this is still
in place and you are removing
what may be ha I don't know how what
percentage of the funding it is but
what's left seems to be businesses and
and individual households
so what what is the result of removing
the funding that is paid by
municipalities and uh
and the state and what services do the
state and municipalities lose or do they
still on
are they still eligible for the benefits
of this program thank you
thank you representative All Me for the
questions I'll try to remember them all
uh in the first place I'm not trying to
eliminate the RPS I'm trying to save
taxpayers money the impact on the RPS
program from this bill will be roughly I
estimate about five million dollars a
year the program generates about 70
million dollars a year for renewable
energy so the impact on the RPS itself
will not be particularly great but it
will provide some relief for taxpayers
uh well cities and towns lose anything
by not paying the RPS no they won't uh
the RPS is
a program that supports renewable energy
people who already have created a
renewable energy
generation project
as they produce energy they collect
renewable energy or they sell renewable
energy certificates and collect the
money from that sale
so uh
towns not paying for the RPS don't lose
anything and in fact the exemption from
paying the RPS reduces the electric
supplier or producers load and
[Music]
requires them to buy fewer renewable
energy certificates
so the only impact will be that if you
uh
a number of renewable energy
certificates will not be required to be
next question
so the net result is that there would be
five million less money going into the
RPS
which creates
um programs
that on are used by cities and towns and
they will still be able to use them but
there will be five million less dollars
in the system
and I would also like a comment on the
fact that that the standard ideology of
your party is that if you on let the
cities and towns have more money they're
just going to increase spending
somewhere else
thank you once again for the question it
helps taxpayers by giving towns the
option of lowering their property tax
rates and they can opt in to the program
and continue paying the RPS if they want
to with a vote of their governing body
so that gives their local taxpayers the
option of saying yes we want to do this
or no we don't want to do this we want
to save money
so I think that that would be a signal
to local uh select people and and City
councilors if if the citizens of the
community say that they want to receive
these savings one would hope that the
local officials would pass those along
representative
of Romney followed by representative
Ames
thank you Mr chair uh thank you very
representative
um I'm still trying to understand why we
have this bill
but
um you can help me with that but will
you say savings to taxpayers
I understand that but how about savings
to rate payers
because of this bill
this bill doesn't save rate payers at
all except for municipal uh
the municipality itself which is a
ratepayer so the the city or town is a
ratepayer and this bill will lower their
electricity costs by a certain amount
and as a result uh taxpayers will
potentially
uh
have to spend less money to to run their
government operations so that's how that
your mood is the
decade got it sorry to be slow on that
um
so I want to inquire about the
alternative compliance payments
that in effect
those who are energy suppliers supplying
to the state or political subdivision
that has not opted out
will no longer have to make
um and uh
um that in my mind is affecting
um essentially a fee or revenues that
otherwise would flow into a state
agency's fund the renewable energy fund
so I think it's pertinent to our review
of this bill
um so um then my question to you
representative votes to start with I've
got a series of questions really is if
you consider
to
competitive let's call them let's just
focus on the competitive electricity
suppliers that Supply the state
with its energy
one of which
has installed and invested money over
the years in
[Music]
um
um forms of energy that conform to that
enable
it to earn renewable energy certificates
or wrecks
and so when at times time comes to uh
even up with the state it it
points to its wrecks and it meets its
its renewable portfolio standard
um and then a second
electricity supplier
that hasn't done that that hasn't made
investments in its plant hasn't
developed let's say the solar field that
that other
supplier is using to supply to build up
its us
supply of energy at sourcing of energy
its generation of energy
um so it this other energy supplier
hasn't done that it has no racks it it
it
can purchase the wrecks or it can pay an
alternative compliance fund uh payment
into the energy fund
um and now it's going to be exempt
and under this bill if this bill is
enacted so we go look forward to next
year when it's all in place
and the first
supplier that has put money into
its own plant
um
continues to carry those costs
and really gains nothing from this
exemption other than
um well maybe it gains nothing uh let's
leave it at that the other supplier
is now
has an exception
and under the bill it negotiates reduced
rates uh to reflect that so it's going
to now be under bidding the first
electrics of supplier that all of this
strikes me as unfair
and unreasonable
okay thank you for that complicated
question so competitive suppliers don't
receive any kind of an exemption under
this
legislation the only entities that
receive an exemption are political
subdivisions
so
let's use my town of Epping as an
example let's say today we're spending
uh two hundred and twenty thousand
we buy our electricity from eversource
we don't use a competitive supplier but
under this bill that bill would be
reduced
by eight thousand dollars roughly or
nine thousand dollars based on the fact
that the uh the company would no longer
charge us for the RPS portion of their
rate they would subtract that before
they charged the town of Epping
and that's how the system works it's
it's it's actually fairly simple
with regard to your comment about uh
alternative compliant compliance
payments and the sale of wrecks
neither of those things would be
affected by this bill
alternative compliance payments are
purchased by energy suppliers
if there are no wrecks to purchase
if there are wrecks to purchase they
purchase wrecks instead but if they if
this the system runs out of Rex then
they'll purchase alternative compliant
they'll make alternative compliance
payments
and those payments don't do go to the
renewable energy of fund but none of
that is impacted by this legislation
that's a completely separate uh
operation that happens outside the
purview of what's going on here this is
a simple exemption of political
subdivisions from paying the RPS portion
of the Energy Service rate that they
would normally be charged by their
supplier
follow-up
representings you have any thoughts yes
sir I think I'm are you hearing me
yeah I think you are
um
yeah I I first I'd say that
this is complex stuff and I hope that
we'll have a little time in uh reviewing
this bill in a work session so that we
can take it
more than we can here through a few
questions
um but uh I I guess my follow-up
question is uh isn't the renewable
energy fund going to lose money
um is the result of this bill
in other words there will be I believe
the entirety of the renewable energy
fund comes from alternative compliance
payments
and will there not be less money because
of this bill
thank you for the question actually the
renewable energy fund gets
most of its funding from alternative
compliance payments but it gets some
funding elsewhere as well and the answer
to your question is uh
in recent experience there have not been
very many alternative compliance
payments made to this to the renewable
energy fund simply because there have
been plenty of wrecks for producers to
buy so there hasn't been a need for
making alternative compliance payments
the amount of money that would be
decreased by this program would be
extremely small
as far as alternative compliance
payments are concerned it's hard to
estimate it exactly but if the whole
program only
decreases RPS intake by 5 million
alternative client compliance payments
are a small fraction of that so it would
be
a very small amount
all right I'm going to leave it at that
thank you
um representative can you uh
provide the committee we were bulletize
uh explanation of the questions and your
response because this is complicated
so if you could provide the committee
with a bulletized
uh summary of the questions and response
okay I'll try I didn't take notes so I
can't promise that I'll remember what
all the questions were but
um I'll do my best thank you
uh I noticed in the attendees as early
oxhamp has her hand up no Norm you got
you got some questions still from the
members
all right uh yes representative hacken
Phillips
here and uh thank you representative
boss for or Bose excuse me if I'm
mispronouncing your name
um for testifying this morning
in support of this bill and um giving us
kind of an introduction of what we can
expect
um just as a point of um following up on
your last question this is being
recorded So I think you can go back and
take a look at you know the
conversations that we're having
but if I if I understand correctly your
last statement is that you know buy your
estimates there's gonna be about a five
million dollar
you know decrease in revenues for the
fund as a result of this legislative
change
um and you're saying that's a small
fraction
um
you know kind of the overall programming
uh that's being expended here out of the
fund so my question is that
you know my understanding is that the
state of New Hampshire has to
demonstrate its willingness to be
investing in types of programs to
address our transition to Renewables in
order to you know receive matching or
other sources of funding from federal
levels as well as you know private
organizations and if if we have a five
million dollar decrease
um how is that going to affect our
eligibility for receiving those matching
grants moving forward
thank you for the question uh just to
clarify what I said was that uh
a decrease in alternative compliance
payments to the program would be a small
percentage of the total RPS program not
uh a small percentage of the 5 million
although it would also be a small
percentage of the 5 million uh to answer
your question as far as I know there is
no dependence on the RPS program and any
kinds of federal or or other
funding that the state might obtain uh
about renewable energy so there's
nothing certainly in the rsas about the
RPS program that indicates that it has
to stay at a certain level in order to
receive to be eligible for federal
funding there's nothing in the
uh just as a follow-up
uh no I I think maybe we're just talking
past each other a little bit I think
there's eligibility requirements of
alternate sources of funding to be
applied towards renewable energy
programs if our state can also
demonstrate that we're you know putting
forth an effort to a certain threshold
and my question is does this legislation
change our ability to meet that
threshold for matching funds
I'm not aware that there is any such
threshold
um but if you can show me that there is
such a threshold I'll take a look at
that
um representative
so is in your muted sorry this is uh
fairly new to me but
um if
the the the money that goes into this
fund is mostly from
on
from
the uh what do you call those things on
the
the purchase of the
um certificates
and
uh the wrecks
and this money and then if there aren't
enough wrecks people are are paying for
the alternative energy
uh
energy uh certificate or whatever it is
I'm sorry
um then
wouldn't these be replaceable between
themselves within a budget that on
people are either paying for one
entities are either paying for one or
for the other and
um
I'm when you were calculating the 5
million were you including the effect on
not paying for
the
um the wreck
in
in consideration of what was going to be
lost or or were you
maybe this is in your testimony I'm
sorry but it came yesterday afternoon I
think and I was erect by the evening
thank you for your question yeah I think
a lot of us were wrecks by yesterday
evening uh
I'll try to answer the two questions uh
the latter question
um
I've already forgotten
you asked what is the impact okay so the
way the RPS program works is if I own a
renewable energy
facility
I generate so many megawatt hours of
electricity during the course of a year
and I'm allowed to claim or to to
acquire one renewable energy certificate
for every one megawatt hour of
electricity that I sell so let's say I
sell 100 of them at the end of the year
I can sell those
renewable energy certificates on a kind
of an open market
there's all kinds of people out there
who will buy them
let's say the price for one of those uh
certificates is 25 dollars so I can sell
my 100 renewable energy certificates for
if there are not enough buyers out there
who want to buy these certificates and
energy suppliers are the ones that buy
them like utility companies
if they're not enough certificates out
there for them to buy then they have to
make an alternative compliance payment
uh instead and that money goes to the
renewable energy fund which is managed
by the puc
so that's the way the system works and
uh this legislation that I've proposed
here today won't have a significant
impact on
either aspect of the program because the
program generates around 70 million
dollars a year and this the exemptions
that I'm talking about will only reduce
the
Financial impact on the whole program by
no more than five million dollars
and as I mentioned at the beginning of
my testimony there are already five
communities in the state that don't
participate in the program so it's not
like it's an unprecedented program
thank you also could I just have a a
short follow-up if I can on follow-up
yeah um if we are allowing
some places to opt out
and they can
still take advantage of the program
on then
isn't that unfair to everybody else that
can't opt out as I recall there there's
one on Electric Cooperative in the North
country that's fairly close to us and
they did opt out but they also through
their shareholders the towns that are
involved they have voted to carry out a
number of alternative energy programs on
their own
so that one seems to be separated off
from the general program of the state
but it sounds like what you're saying is
that the others that would opt out now
would would still be part of the general
energy program of the state
can you clarify for us thank you
sure thank you I I think you're maybe
over complicating this question it's a
simple question really do you want to
give cities and towns the chance to
reduce their or the opportunity to
reduce their electricity costs
which would then enable them to
pass those savings along to their
taxpayers that's that's the simple
question here
its effect on the renewable portfolios
standard is not particularly great yes
it will reduce it some small amount but
it's not an amount that is significant
and
as far as I'm concerned taxpayer relief
as the governor indicated in his budget
address earlier this year is a more
okay anybody else wish to testify I wish
then we will go to the representative
yeah
okay who does
all right
oh okay I didn't say your name uh go
ahead represent names
you're just focus in on that last
comment about uh
um
savings at the municipal level
isn't it the case that many
municipalities have taken advantage of
the renewable energy fund to make
investments that have lowered their
annual consumption of electricity so
that uh in effect there these
municipalities and others that may
benefit in the future from a healthy
robust renewable energy fund or in fact
saving more than they uh will save
through uh through your proposal
Representatives
uh thank you for that question and the
answer to your question is this
legislation gives towns the option of
continuing to pay into the renewable
energy fund and continuing to take
advantage of the grant opportunities
that the renewable energy fund may offer
uh the town has to vote to opt into the
program again because it's an opt-out
program by default but the option is
there so if local taxpayers want to
participate in the RPS program they can
uh they can do so by instructing their
governor governing body to opt them back
representations
so that's interesting so could you
clarify uh I don't see it in the
legislation if a municipality
I'm not sure which is opted in or opt
out this chooses to take advantage of
the exemption
does that mean that they cannot receive
a grant from the renewable energy fund
or and in parallel if a state agency
um
wants to go forward with a renewable
energy funded project to get a rebate of
some sort
um does uh the fact that it the state
gets this exemption meaning that that
project uh is no longer eligible for the
renewable energy fund again I don't see
yes thank you for that question yes it's
in um
the paragraph I think it's uh I don't
have it right in front of me but I think
it's paragraph e it uh states that this
is an opt-out program so that when it
when it takes effect communities are all
automatically automatically Exempted
from paying the RPS but they can opt
back in by a vote of their governing
body
so that's how the program works and yes
you are correct they do have to opt back
in in order to be eligible to uh request
grants from the new renewable energy
fund but that option is there for them
so voters in a town can make that
well
I guess I'd like to leave it there
representative major but again I think
this is uh there are details here and
complexities that need to be reviewed in
a work session
okay there is one of trendy that's on
the list uh it's an opposition so Jimmy
could you let
I just promoted her representative
oxenham
Lee Oxford
okay representative oxen
uh
you're in opposition you're all set to
testify
I don't have that capability to unmute
someone
and I think we lost her I don't oh no
she's still there just everything just
shifted I think she's trying to connect
it looks like
I don't see her in his attendees are in
the floor uh no I think I think she got
dropped
maybe she'll try to come back
or comments
I don't see anything from the
participate the panelists I'm sorry
Mr chairman uh representative
I think it would be helpful if we could
get someone from the program I presume
it's under the puc
to talk with us about this at a work
session
right and thank you and represent oxen
can join us at a work session if you
can't come back right away
um
uh actually there's a Diane Martin with
you have to unmute yourself there you go
Diane Martin
good morning good morning Mr chair
members of the committee my name is
Diane Martin I am the chairwoman of the
Public Utilities Commission I just I'm
on for the next hearing but overheard
you say that it would be helpful to have
someone from the puc on a work session
so I wanted to say we'd be happy to do
that fine thank you
all right any
we are running well over time
so I don't see any other hands raised so
I'm going to close the public hearing on
okay well she popped in and then
she must be having a lot of trouble yeah
she's there she's still there
hasn't been promoted yet well it takes a
um
yeah she's here she's on the second page
you know what we'll do and she'll just
have to join us
on the work session because we are way
behind okay
oh oh well she has her hand up but
can you unmutely we we only
Gen 4 is there a way to unmute her I
don't know how I mean I don't have that
capability
foreign
will probably have to contact Jen she's
watching two two committees today yeah
yeah
well I guess
maybe what um
yeah
oh there she is she's unmuted
but we can't hear you
that's it right representative oxen
hey Jenny just to make a clarification
she actually isn't connected to audio it
said she tried and then yeah like that
she's trying to connect and then she her
audio there you go now she is oh now
oh boy Tiana is she on a phone or is
this Earth connection
um it's not a phone number hello can you
hear there we go yes oh my Lord I
apologize profusely that it has taken me
so much of your time for me to get on I
will submit written testimony I will I
will keep my remarks to one minute
I don't believe that you have had a fair
and accurate
description of how this is going to
impact our towns and our municipalities
nor our ability to profit by all of the
federal funding that's going to be
coming to States in our region who are
pursuing aggressive renewable energy
strategies and I I do not think it's
fair to characterize this as a simple
process it is complex and I I know that
representative votes will do his best to
answer your questions and I will too
thank you I do apologize and we will be
having a work session so if you could
send us that your testimony that would
be appreciated I certainly shall
let me try this once again
any new person wants to testify for or
against house bill 614. I do not
now you're muted representation I just
wanted to ask uh representative oxenham
a question but she may not be able to
answer it at this point uh which is
whether she believes that there is
language in in the statute or in this
bill that uh says that Townsend cities
that do not uh that opt not to pay the
uh renewable energy uh fee are going to
lose the ability to use the renewable
energy funding
uh thank you very much for the question
and it's my understanding that we
discussed this in our committee and we
actually had an amendment produced to
ensure that there could not be a
possibility of double dipping if towns
were not paying in they could not access
the renewable energy fund uh if that
this bill would make it so that
everybody is out unless they
affirmatively enter in and so
anyone who has opted out without
possibly even knowing it is going to be
unable to access the renewable energy
fund and just as a final note there we
have no fossil fuel Energy System
um energy suppliers here in New
Hampshire it's all important we spend
billions of dollars and send them out of
state every year we have a thriving
renewable energy sector which is poised
to grow and we may be able to get
substantial Federal funding this year if
we are seen as active participants in
assisting our renewable energy sector
and I think that representative hacken
Phillips is correct that we would be
endangering that if if this bill were to
pass
but I thought there was an amendment
produced is it in this bill
I I believe the bill as it came to you
should and have Incorporated that uh
Amendment perhaps we could ask chairman
Vose as it was his Amendment as I recall
you need to unmute uh representing both
sorry I was just looking on the general
court website and the amendment is there
but it's not part of the bill that comes
up when you click on the bill itself so
apparently the two haven't been merged
together yet well the copy I have says
it doesn't look right to me but I'll
double check again I just took a quick
look while we were online here I'll I'll
get back to you I'll take another look
thank you on another question with that
one is the state also unable to access
if the state opts out which I gather the
bill opposite out
that would be a consequence of passing
any further questions
yeah I just I want to
follow up on that discussion
um I hope that somebody will explain to
us how the bill as amended by the house
indeed accomplishes what has just been
said
um about it that it uh that the state
by virtue of the bill and political
subdivisions that
that are not going to be participating
in uh in the RPS
system are going to take advantage of
this exemption
um will be excluded from participating
the renewable energy fund I just want to
be I don't I don't see it in the
language and maybe I'm missing something
so if
representative boss would be prepared to
come up with an answer for that for our
and representative spillsbury
yes for you then yes
just to clarify on the house session
last a week before
um the amendment was adopted on a Voice
vote
and then the bill was
otpa
at 198 150. so I assume that's the same
amendment that representative is
describing
yeah and I I've seen that amendment I I
think we just need to
I need anyway to be educated on its
impact
anything
because we are going to the work session
to address these issues
send nothing I was say no more hands up
so I'm going to close the public hearing
were any other members of the public
unable to get into this session if may I
not that we know of well in the work
session
I I believe there were others who
attempted to sign in and wanted to
testify that's why I raised the question
thank you
I looked at the attendees there's nobody
else
and I looked at
a sign up sheet
only one person
signed up to testify and that's you
in opposition
thank you thank you for the information
perhaps they
we will go right into the public hearing
oh
615 Dash FN
reducing the penalty for certain first
okay we have signed up
as a co-sponsor to introduce the bill
and represented
representing Casey mcconnelly here
so I just promoted him
okay
aye Mr chairman committee members you're
able to hear me okay yes all right
excellent
um yes uh thank you all for having me
I'm Casey Conway state representative
from Dover representing Stratford County
District 13 here
um on behalf of the Prime sponsor
representative seaworth
um and speaking as a co-sponsor
um
so I guess I'll start with uh some some
details on the origin of this bill so
the policy side of this uh contains
essentially two Provisions that were
introduced last year
um that died both past the house on the
consent calendar
they died in the covid shortened session
um and they re-emerged this year
representative seaworth um to his credit
uh took two Provisions that uh that had
passed I worked with myself worked with
the other Democratic co-sponsor on
creating This truly bipartisan bill
uh that aims to sort of streamline and
reform our sentencing statute for uh
drug offenses non-violent drug offenses
so specifically what this would do
um there's four main Provisions the
first is it reduces top end penalties
for non-violent drug crimes so sentences
and fines and it better aligns them with
what's already happening in courthouses
across the state
it eliminates the possibility of a
felony for the first time possession
level offense
it eliminates the mandatory minimum
sentences that we had and we had a
number of them just a small handful but
those would go away worth noting there's
still no mandatory maximum but it does
go up to life in prison that is still an
option for for any sentence here
um and it lowers this is uh so those are
sort of a a reduction this would
actually strengthen the penalty for
fentanyl Possession It lowers the
threshold to be charged with a felony
and that uh comports with what we know
about the dangerousness and the
seriousness of fentanyl in very small
quantities there is a fiscal note to
this bill
um and it indicates an indeterminable
decrease
um in state and County costs and that
reflects the lower cost of Prosecuting a
case at the uh at the district level
versus the Superior Court level for a
felony and there is an indeterminable
decrease in Revenue
um
from Fine Collection but uh it's worth
noting and you'll see this in the
analysis in the bill that um
there's essentially no significant
impact in that Revenue collection
so uh um with that uh you know I'm a
Believer in the bill I support the bill
uh it's past the house again on a Voice
vote this term and I would ask the
committee to uh look kindly and please
recommend passage as well thank you
thank you for your testimony
representative Conley you take questions
absolutely
uh representative Bromley followed by
representative
yeah can we uh thank you for your
testimony thank you Mr chair thank you
for your testimony um
let's talk about fentanyl uh I'm trying
to in the bill I'm trying to understand
I see on on uh first page line
28 talking about some kind of a quantity
um so what is the current has that
penalty changed for Fentanyl
and can you tell us what that penalty is
for fentanyl first time
um thank you representative abrami so
this this bill the last two years so the
the reduction in sentencing is uh was my
bill from last term what you see before
you includes a friendly Amendment from
representative Roy uh that carried over
into this bill so the fentanyl piece to
directly answer your question
uh if you read this statute and if you
what this statue does is it doesn't say
if you do X you get y punishment uh it
includes discretion for prosecutors
based on everything you read to look at
the circumstances of a case and charge
accordingly so
if you look and so I don't have the pay
I'm looking at this on my computer
screen
um but if you look in
um
version you'll see the numbering yes so
I see uh you know fentanyl a fentanyl
class drug on I believe section
three
or section one
parentheses three
um fentanyl is crossed out so prior to
this bill
one could possess up to five grams of
fentanyl under the proposal that's
before you now uh fentanyl would trigger
uh this more serious felony type offense
uh if one were to possess 0.5 gram or
more so 5 grams which was a quite a
large quantity for this type of drug to
0.5 and then if you look further down in
the bill there's a lower threshold of
punishment that includes fewer years in
prison and so forth the trigger for this
one would be 0.25 grams so we're we're
really Bringing Down the amount that one
could possess without opening oneself up
to Serious uh felony level
charges and prison time
if I hope that answers your question and
that help that helps thank you
uh representative followed by represent
Hackman Phillips
thank you Mr chairman on excellent
Conley I I think I remember that .01
gram of fentanyl uh could kill
a police officer or other person that
um thank you so uh
I don't know the weight of a lethal dose
of fentanyl it is a a minuscule amount
but if you read the bill it also
includes uh program including any
adulterants and uh what we know is that
uh heroin itself is is typically not
that that's it's less heroin in our
state now and it's fentanyl included
with other stuff so uh you don't need to
have 0.25 grams or 0.5 gram of fentanyl
to trigger this it's
that small quantities of fentanyl
whatever is typically included in a
street level sale plus the other stuff
that is in it is enough to trigger the
higher penalty if that makes sense
Phillips thank you Mr here
representative Conley thank you so much
for your commitment to this type of
Criminal Justice Reform which is
probably long overdue and for your
introduction today
um you stated that this bill is
codifying the practice of many courts
across our state and reducing the
penalties and sentences
attributable to these types of crimes
um would you speak to the Penalty side
of that detail and um you know what is
the difference between the statutes
requirements and the practice of
collecting those fines and penalties
thank you for that question so if you
look um
that
uh the question you asked can be best
addressed by looking at the the top
section of the bill and what you'll see
is
um you know a prison term that may have
been 20 years or excuse me 30 years
before would now have a maximum of 20
the fine would go from half a million to
300 000 and I'm just cherry picking if
as you read the bill there are a handful
of cases in which uh years are reduced
uh in a moderate way and fines are
reduced and this is not just someone
taking a black marker and Crossing stuff
off it's really
um looking at what's actually being
charged to people and what fines are
being assessed so
um
well I can't uh give you a definitive
answer for how much somebody typically
gets fined and so forth the reality is
nobody is being Char fined a half
million dollars in New Hampshire nobody
is being fined three hundred thousand
dollars and if they were it's unlikely
that fine would be paid so this is just
bumping it down to a level that is
I also represent acting Phillips
okay representative personal Nunes
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative Conley for coming in I'm
delighted to see a bipartisan effort
seeing you work with my friend uh
representative seeworth on this bill
um I am a person that believes very much
in recovery assistance for people who
have dependence issues or things like
that
um I want you to confirm with me I'm
reading in the methodology that no
additional there will be no additional
cost to the Department of Justice or
criminal justice Bureau in this bill I
believe that's what I read in the
methodology can you just confirm that
with me foreign
yeah so
I I will never say never I don't know
what scenarios one might encounter but
uh in the the premise that here is that
uh prosecution costs would go down for
fewer felony charges particularly the
first time right so the first time
possession level would be bumped down to
a misdemeanor well now one does not have
to uh adjudicate that process at the
superior court level
so that's the intent that's what I
foresee happening that is what the
testimony leading up to today has
suggested
uh I
I can't tell you that nothing would ever
lead to a higher cost uh for the
apartment but that's the intent and
that's what we've been heard that's what
we've heard
thank you representative Conley and
thank you Mr chairman
uh representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Conley uh just two
questions just to clarify
these are for drug possession only
correct not the distribution
and number true God
and number two I would agree with
representative Almy that even a
minuscule amount of fentanyl can be a
very dangerous drug and would you ever
consider it uh being uh more more
specific to any possession of fentanyl
versus any specific amount thank you
thank you so um
can I answer the second one first
because I honestly forgot your first one
I'm sorry and I'll ask you to restate it
but um to that question around fentanyl
this has been this is a number that um
uh threads the needle of being too harsh
for some people and not harsh enough for
others it really comes down in the
middle and reflects
um
I think I'm not going to say happy
medium when we're talking about a killer
drug but it it's really a threshold that
that law enforcement is comfortable with
um
I'm seeing head shaking uh let me stop
if the committee wishes to make an
amendment to this bill
um that is the committee's prerogative
and I'll leave it there
and his other question was uh
distribution
yeah so this bill nothing about this is
giving
a free pass to anyone involved in
trafficking there's a separate
trafficking statute major traffickers
are charged with federal crimes uh
trafficking often yields ancillary
charges uh that none of that is touched
under this and I that's a good question
and I want to be very clear this is not
about selling this is possession type
offenses
thank you as just my experience is that
any fentanyl is probably very dangerous
outside of control setting like an
operating room
but thank you for your response
representative
okay uh sorry about that my cursor froze
for a second uh thank you Mr chairman
and thank you representative Conley for
taking my question
um as someone who's not not familiar
with uh
um this topic I guess I'll just ask you
in an era where crime seems to be
spiking around the country
um are you concerned at all that that
lessening penalties could encourage
um additional use and further crime
thank you for the question and this
question has been addressed multiple
times fortunately I can I'm comfortable
answering it but through through the
policy committee so this has come up
last term in criminal justice this term
in criminal justice and
um
this doesn't mean that somebody who
commits a serious drug crime doesn't go
to prison there's if you read through
the bill you
you could still be sentenced to life in
prison and there are people in our state
serving up serving sentences that
include up to life in prison that
wouldn't change under this bill uh this
is a this is a if you you know this is
really about possession level offenses
not trafficking uh not uh violence uh
that may occur in the uh through drug
sales that's all covered in separate
criminal statutes and they're all uh I
mean we've heard testimony in criminal
justice that our statutes need to come
down none of that would occur this is
really about possession type offenses
um
so and
and again when you read through the
statute there's still teeth here it just
means that somebody wouldn't be
sentenced to to a maximum of 30 years it
might be 20. uh it might be
um five years instead of seven
that to me is still a pretty significant
prison time
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman on
if we
um put fentanyl at any
fentanyl uh and since this is possession
most of the people that on
are on drugs and get some LSD I didn't
know it was still around or mass or or
anything like that that has a small
amount of fentanyl in it will not know
until their
their dying of it probably
um that they've gotten something with
fentanyl and I'm I'm concerned when if
we put it down to zero whether we would
be capturing a fair number of people
that
that would
on would not really realize that that's
what what they had and whether there's a
defense against that ignorance we talk
there is no Revenue in this bill
we shouldn't have had this Bill thank
you
all right let's Hold It Down
anybody else on the panelists with
questions
yeah thank you Mr chair I've got another
question for you uh representative
Connolly
is it is my memory says just a week or
two ago didn't we have a baby that died
in the state
and if if that is the case how I think
it was New Hampshire right
uh I remember reading in the paper but
let's use that example even if it wasn't
New Hampshire
that those folks the parents which still
could still be charged criminally
couldn't they
for negligence
that that substance to be near the
infant I was fentanyl I know it was
Fentanyl thank you representative I'm
not familiar with the case although it
sounds like a tragedy that
does occur from time to time so our
criminal statutes are voluminous they
cover nearly all scenarios that one
might encounter
um from Reckless uh you know Reckless
Behavior to
[Music]
um
it just runs the gamut so it's it's safe
to say that if somebody commits the act
that you just described they would be uh
subject to numerous penalties well
beyond what is covered in this
possession type uh statute so
um the fentanyl piece has been well
vetted at the policy committee level uh
the committee has noted some concerns
these are things we've heard all before
but I I
as I noted I it's the committee's
prerogative to the representatives
question
um
yeah I mean there are numerous penalties
that a person would face under the
scenario you described okay thank you
any other questions from the panelists
as we have three attendees that want to
all right um
the first Mr chairman I'm I'm going to
depart the meeting because I'm in
committee and I'm being summoned by my
chair to do an exact session but if
anyone has questions I'm happy to talk
about this representative seeworth the
other co-sponsors I'm sure would happy
to be happy to answer questions but I
just wanted to say I'll be gone and I
won't be able to answer anything that
might arise well thank you
representative thank you all take care
do you mean you want to send Let's uh
Mr Fowler
I just did
I oh peace
um Mr Fowler is a member of the public
in support of the bill and said he has
three minutes of like the testing
oh there he is
right
uh good afternoon chairman and committee
can y'all hear me yes
awesome well thank you all for hearing
me out today and I also sent a letter
this morning that will kind of get into
the details of you know why I stand in
support of this bill I'm first and
foremost a person in long-term recovery
I both use and sold drugs in New
Hampshire for over 10 years and have
been in recovery for the past six years
I'm a Certified Recovery support worker
and run a harm reduction program in the
Upper Valley New Hampshire and Vermont
uh I'm currently involved in some
research at the Dartmouth Institute
focusing on drug use and health care and
I've also done some other research and I
really support this bill with the idea
that we're going to not criminalize
people with substance use disorders and
give them a felony when they're first
you know for their first mistake their
first charge and
um but really when it comes down to the
latter parts of the bill that get into
Fentanyl and being specific in
scheduling it really makes no sense it
is really
um inaccurate and complicated and if you
really wanted to save money given this
is you know kind of the Ways and Means
Committee we would simplify this and not
try to criminalize people and argue over
fractions of a gram a lot of my clients
in recent years have reported they use
five to ten grams of fentanyl a day the
difference being The Binding agent
because because most of this killer
fentanyl we're talking about the super
potent pure uncut stuff doesn't come
into New Hampshire in that way it's
usually coming in with a binding agent
it's most of that binding agent so
people who are low level you know
substance use disorder people with a
daily habit of five to ten grams are
oftentimes mislabeled a dealer and
there's really not much of a difference
between a drug user and a drug dealer
they're oftentimes the same person
because there's no grocery store to go
to and so I would really advocate for
passing this bill because we know that
prohibition doesn't work the idea seems
to make sense at first if we prohibit
something it will prevent it from
happening but we know that prohibition
gave us fentanyl in the overdose crisis
and everything before us we know that
this is a system that makes addictive
disorders worse and criminalizing people
taking people into captivity and taking
away their rights does nothing to
support recovery and so I love that this
bill is moving away from criminal model
and towards a public health model but I
would really advocate for simplifying
the scheduling apparatus rather than
complicating it and there's a whole long
discussion for each line item for each
drug it's subjective it's not based in
science and um yeah that's happy to
answer questions but I I do think this
bill is a step in the right direction
it's uh so thank you thank you for your
testimony Mr Fowler questions from the
committee
what you think
no questions thank you the next can uh
attendee is Tony narrow
if you could let him in yep just did yep
and a member of the public from the New
Hampshire Association of criminal
defense lawyers
in support of the bill
and it would like three minutes to
testify
good morning can everyone hear me okay
yes thank you um yes my name is Anthony
narrow I am speaking as a representative
of the New Hampshire Association of
criminal defense lawyers I have been a
criminal defense attorney uh for over 12
years
um I went to Private Practice in
November so the majority of my career
has been with the New Hampshire public
defender in Rockingham and Hillsborough
counties both North and South
um I want to talk today about the
financial impact of this bill as it
relates to how fentanyl is addressed on
the other aspects which the prior
speaker just addressed are some social
justice issues which I agree with but I
I want to focus on the financial impact
here today though I'll answer questions
about any Topic at any time
in the 1980s Congress made a critical
error by creating a disparity a
disparity disparity and sentencing
between crack cocaine and powder cocaine
and for decades poor people and
disproportionately uh black people found
themselves spending a significant period
of time in prison and this led to a
costly spike in the prison population
Nationwide and it didn't end the crack
epidemic what it did from the
perspective of taxpayers was squander
millions and millions of taxpayer
dollars and I'm hoping that we don't
make that mistake here in New Hampshire
when it comes to Fentanyl
fentanyl is being sold in the same
quantities as heroin because that is
what people are used to buying as a
prior speaker just noted if you are a
two gram a day heroin user you're going
to continue buying two grams a day of
fentanyl now it's not actually two
actual grams of fentanyl it's mostly the
The Binding agent the adulterants and
um you know what we call on the street
cut so if you're buying a gram of
fentanyl or heroin and everyone it's
interchangeable they'll say I need a
gram of brown
and they might get heroin they might get
fentanyl they don't know
um but they're not getting an actual
gram of fentanyl it's all cut
um and so what is sold is really the
adulterants and dilutants so to say that
well
um five grams or more or 0.5 grams or
more including the the luteins or
adulterants is going to significantly
punish those who possess a a substance
containing fentanyl more than one person
possessing the same amount of heroin
um even though the two drugs are being
used interchangeably on the street
there's no difference in the mental
state for the crime
um and and this is this was the problem
with the crack cocaine and powder
cocaine problem and it's happening all
over again in this bill we know more
about addiction than we did in the 1980s
and we know that we can't incarcerate
our way out of the problem
um that's not how our taxpayers money
should be invested we do know that
investing in substance abuse treatment
we just heard somebody in recovery for
six years
um investing in substance abuse
treatment which includes our drug courts
which are very successful in the state
we should be proud of mental health
treatment and Social Services that's
what's effective and the benefit of
combating addiction in an effective way
is beyond social it's also good for the
bottom line it's good for taxpayers it
reduces the amount of money we need to
spend on incarcerated people in the
short term and long term because when
you think about the short term okay
that's forty thousand dollars a year for
a prison sentence but we know about
recidivism in this state and how high
the recidivism rates are and parole
violation so they're going back to
prison we also know that once their
prison sentence is up they are going to
be more likely to recidivate and commit
another crime so we have long-term costs
as well if they don't receive treatment
so investing in treatment rather than
increasing penalties
um for fentanyl possession which again
is is treating addicts unequally
um and is not based in science and is
not considering the small amounts of
fentanyl in an actual bag compared to
the cut
is a problem financially
I'm sorry yes
the policy has been passed by the
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee
we're only interested in the revenue
aspects of this and the amount of the
fines and things so if you could
address that and yet I think signed up
for three minutes and you've gone over
that so if you could just arrested just
to address the revenue part of it I
appreciate it yes thank you and I
apologize if I went off off
um your agenda you know as far as
Revenue goes
um I don't see a revenue benefit to this
um
to this statue I mean there are
mandatory fines I think the mandatory
fines should go away if you are finding
somebody who is a poor addict whether
it's 500 as a mandatory fine or thirty
thousand dollars which you know they'll
never be able to pay
um why do we have that provision in the
statute
um it it it's it's not very logical to
me and so that's my position as far as
the fines go
um and I do think
um so that's that's that's my answer to
that question
um with respect to uh representative
abrami who asked about the the toddler
who passed away
um cert that uh couple was charged with
negligent homicide
um if just to answer your question about
that it was it was two parents they were
charged with negligent homicide and um
under some circumstances you could be
charged in theory with manslaughter
um for recklessly causing the death of
another person it all depends on the
circumstances but I just want to answer
that question for you thank you uh Tony
uh that was New Hampshire though right
yes that was New Hampshire I believe it
was a
Manchester case
um and um and they were just arrested in
in Londonderry I believe at the truck
stop the passing of the child didn't
just happen I think that
um it happened a while ago and they just
arrested the parents and that's why it
was in the news but it was undoubtedly
undoubtedly tragic and I think again
speaks to the need for addressing the
social ills that lead to addiction
um so we can have preventative measures
to stop tragedies like this from
happening
thank you right and they they've also I
believe they found the third person that
they're planning on charging for the
same
um that's your testimony Mr Nero all
right yes sir thank you for your
testimony those
to me you have any questions to ask Mr
Nero
I don't see any so we thank you for your
testimony thank you for addressing this
issue have a good day
the next is uh a John griffonsky who's
gentle poison Bedford
he okay I'm yeah opposes it and he wants
well it's taking a while
yes um good morning good morning
um almost afternoon members of the
committee can you hear me
yes
thank you
um my name is John brofanski and I
represent the New Hampshire Association
of Chief employees I'm chairperson of
the chief drug committee and uh just by
way of background um I've been in
continuous service to the public in law
enforcement capacity for more than 42
years having served 27 years of my
career directly dealing with substance
abuse issues and I've been the chief
here coming up on on 10 years the chiefs
of police here in the granite state are
vehemently opposed to this bill
the bill if passed will reduce the
penalties universally used against drug
traffickers and not drug users and have
negligible Financial impact these are
definitely not non-violent crimes in
fact my detectives are working on a
death resulting drug case as we speak as
are many other detectives you most
recently have seen cases in Hudson and
in Merrimack that produce charges with
respect to death resulting cases and
these are definitely not user quantities
as have been discussed in previous
testimony
the reduction in maximum prison time
from 30 to 20 years and from 20 to 15
and from seven to five in various
sections of this bill dilutes the strong
message against drug dealing and dilutes
the ability to obtain just and
reasonable sentences in the most
egregious cases that we see in all
practicality very few people are
currently sentenced to the maximum term
of incarceration so these charges only
serve to hamstring the courts and
prosecutors when addressing The Most
Dangerous Drug traffickers not users by
reducing the penalties used to change to
charge rather drug traffickers who
typically are not drug users we send the
wrong message to drug traffickers whose
only aim is to make money while
destroying the lives of others in
section 1C page two on line 34 the bill
proposes to reduce the maximum sentence
for less than one gram of heroin from
seven to Five Years yet one half gram
equates to 12 bags of heroin or fentanyl
enough to kill 12 people or more in one
quarter gram equates to about six bags
of heroin that can kill at least six or
more people so the bill proposes the
elimination of a one-year minimum
mandatory sentence for selling drugs in
or within one thousand feet of a school
um ladies and gentlemen we should never
listen to penalties for endangering our
children and our youth and the next
generation of Americans in my experience
very few cases of this penalty
enhancement are charged and the reason
why is because the penalty enhancement
and disincentive is in fact is is
effective the bill removes the mandatory
minimum sentence for not less than 25
years for operating a drug Enterprise
these are the worst of the worst of drug
traffickers they are responsible for the
death and destruction of hundreds of
can you concentrate on the revenue
aspects of it primarily
the the effect here is is that the
maximum penalties are rarely charged and
as a result what happens here is the
financial impact here
um is rather negligible and there's been
discussion about
um whether or not this bill addresses
manufacturing or selling it does if you
look at the first page in the first
sentence it refers to manufacturer so
the financial impact here is negligible
but the um unintended consequences of
the message that it sends to drug
traffickers who are very well aware very
well aware of what the quantities are as
they relate to drug sentences is
enormous and that ladies and gentlemen
is is the real issue here uh it sends
the wrong message and the financial
impact while we may be concerned about
how much money uh it Revenue it's not
going to save any money it's not going
to save any money at all uh as a matter
of fact when we look at the cost in
terms of the billions of dollars spent
in the Health Care System dealing with
this system in a drug treatment
prevention it it it it hasn't probably
an increase uh in what those costs are
so the financial impact uh Mr chair is
negligible but the unintended quantity
consequences here are enormous
oh thank you for your testimony Chief uh
questions from the committee
representative Bromley
Mr chair thank you thank you chief
um
so now I'm really confused because the
earlier testimony said
that this had nothing to do with dealers
or or traffickers
but you I just read what you just said
on that first paragraph and it does talk
about traffickers and so forth
so can you just re-emphasize your point
because you feel that this bill does
thank you so much for your question
um and yes it it most certainly deals
with traffickers the the heavy penalties
that you see 30 years currently in law
um in 20 years currently in law those
are sentences related to quantities of
drugs controlled drugs that are are
not user possession quantities they are
trafficking quantities this bill
um is flying under false colors in that
it attempts to reduce
um the the penalties for drug
trafficking and not users it most
certainly deals in and it's as the first
sentences say uh in this bill most
certainly addresses director but the
quantities involved uh representative
are absolutely drug trafficking
quantities not drug user quantities and
the previous testimony with respect to
how much fentanyl can kill a person
the amount of fentanyl that can kill a
person sits on the head of a pen
the head of a pen right that's enough to
kill somebody a police officer and other
people and again we're dealing with
death resulting cases right here in
Bedford we're dealing with the tragedy
these are not victimless crimes and any
deaths resulting from drug trafficking
is not a non-violent crime
okay
thank you okay I have to remind
um
policy has been passed and we still have
to concentrate on the revenue aspect of
this
so further questions on the revenue
aspect
whether we like the policy or not
representative
thank you I just wanted to uh tell the
chief of police that he's going to have
to go to the Senate because we cannot do
thank you representative representative
Southworth
uh thank you my questions for the chair
yes representative Southwest I know
we'll have a work session on this but I
think it's really important
um that if there is no significant
effect on Revenue that that's very clear
if we change the
fine to some other
up or down
I guess
my question just is so far the testimony
has been that there is no significant
effect
and uh maybe do we use the dra to make
sure that that is true except for maybe
fewer felony cases which might lower
court costs
um the dra would not be involved with
but I'm just wondering who will clarify
that for our committee I know
okay thank you
and uh I would imagine that we would
hash this out
we have a
work session on those bills that we hear
today that it's not clearly what we want
to act on and we still have some open
questions
uh anything
anybody else questions or comments
I do see there's another handle
I don't I haven't seen that name in the
list to testify that were sent to me
this morning
do you want me to allow him to talk or
um let's listen to what he has to say I
want to find out
okay
um good morning still members of the
committee thank you for listening to me
my name is Joe Hannon
sign up to testify I'm sorry when did
you sign up to testify uh I don't recall
I may have I may I may not have I'm not
sure I signed up to testify for a lot of
bills that it was on my calendar so if I
didn't did it or not if I did not sign
up I apologize but uh I'm here now I'd
like just a minute or two of your time
so just apply for or against in favor of
the legislation
Norm Joe Joe's a former State Rep as
well oh okay representative Hannon
go ahead
thank you um like uh representative
Abram he said I'm a former state
representative and retired doctor I'm
also a person in long-term recovery uh
for over 29 years I'm very actively
involved in the recovery Community with
several uh recovery organizations and
treatment facilities I'm also very
active in the harm reduction community
in New Hampshire
um I I'd like to start off by saying you
know I know this isn't policy but
there's a growing uh body of evidence
that longer prison sentences don't mean
less crime uh and between 1990 and 2005
according to Pew charitable trust time
served for drug offenses Rose in New
Hampshire 14 percent
and the average cost of keeping each
offender in prison at that time which is
16 years ago was 21 644 dollars per
person they kept in prison longer
uh that is a significant cost to the
state that was it's pretty much in line
with the same uh data that the state had
access to they said they hadn't had new
data in 15 years and I now I don't feel
bad about having old data because they
didn't either but um you know that's a
significant cost also to the to the
quest to the comments about the lethal
doses of Fentanyl and Other Drugs
um the state routinely sells alcohol in
a lethal dose of alcohol is five to
eight grams per kilogram of body weight
that's about uh equivalent to a liter or
a little more of a bottle of spirits or
four bottles of wine can kill someone
the state makes hundreds of millions of
dollars selling lethal doses of alcohol
to people on a daily basis
so I I think that uh you know that
that's one thing to consider also there
was mention from a member of your
committee that uh the danger of exposure
to police officers and the deaths
possibly resulting as a concern and
there hasn't been a single documented
overdose case from incidental exposure
contact with fentanyl that's ever been
confirmed or withstood any scrutiny uh
we hear a lot of sensationalized stories
so I think that's something to take into
consideration the cost of keeping people
in jail longer is is definitely a cost
that it needs to be considered by this
committee it was briefly mentioned in
the fiscal note but really I think it
needs to be examined further and also
like representative Conley said the
fines that are mentioned here uh that
are changing it to it's really just
changing it to what the judges already
are doing it's not really reducing
anything
that's not already happening so this is
just almost a uh a procedural change in
my mind as far as what the judicial
branch is already doing
in many ways it may change it from the
Superior Court to the Circuit Court but
uh that is also cheaper something for
you to consider per case to to prosecute
in Circuit Court versus Superior Court
I'd be happy to answer any questions
well thank you for your testimony
representative Hammond any questions
from the committee
representative Allen
thank you Mr chairman uh honorable Hanan
on when
this bill obviously does uh reduce the
penalties and time in prison for the big
dealers
at the same time is it impossible to
create a statute which separates the big
dealers from the the actual users
including a couple of people that deal
um as far as big dealers I mean it uh I
I don't necessarily agree with that
terminology because most people that I
know that have dealt in New Hampshire
that are in recovery and and there's a
lot of research out to the shows most
people that are dealing are actually
users so despite what other people said
it's not true uh you do have people
dealing just for the sake of profit
um this does not say you can't charge
them they can still spend 15 years or 20
years in jail as opposed to 30 or life
for first offenses uh that isn't even
happening for dealers they're not
putting dealers like significant I guess
if you want to use that word dealers in
jail for that period of time on a
regular basis in New Hampshire
um so you know if if most people that
are dealing or doing it to support a
habit I think that is uh it's it's a
it's kind of a
it's a very not a gray area I think it's
a very dark uh Cloud that's put over
people that actually have a problem and
need help and I think a first offense is
the best time to find those people and
actually offer them help instead of
lengthy unnecessary prison sentences
that only cost the state money and don't
you also represent All of Me
I think this ought to be discussed in a
policy committee so
thank you I agree with you
um representatively
yeah that's what representative Wyoming
just said uh this discussion about the
drugs and the effects on individuals had
nothing to do with uh the amount of
money coming uh into the state or the
state effects I really don't understand
why we're even hearing this bill but
that's somebody else's decision thank
you Mr chair
thank you representative early any
further questions if not
Ryan Fowler has his hand raised in
attendees well he's already testified
yes
thank you Mr chairman I'm leaving and
Ryan and Mr Fowler
only speak about the revenue aspects I
don't want to hear anything else
yes sir I'll make it very brief and it's
just in response to the representative
from the police Chiefs Union kind of
um defending the stance of prohibition
and criminalizing is this issue and
treating this Health Care issue as a
criminal issue and I just would say you
know where's the evidence you know
there's no evidence that prohibition
works it's incredibly expensive and when
it comes to an actual fiscal note
conversation that we could have it would
be impossible because jails and prisons
in New Hampshire don't track recidivism
we don't have the ability to track how
effective this is but we know
empirically and I have Bodies of
Evidence I would support it doesn't work
in itself most amounts of money we could
be saving sorry sir Mr father just the
revenue aspect please
yeah I know it's just it's hard to have
that conversation without tracking
recidivism and the efficacy of these
very expensive Endeavors like Granite
shield and criminalizing folks so if we
could compile the cost of what we're
doing now we would see cost Savings in
reducing criminal charges in court
hearings you know uh incarcerating
people Etc we just need some numbers to
start with and so I want to say we need
to track outcomes better
thank you
sin none
any further questions or comments from
the committee members and then I'm
closing the public hearing on House Bill
615.
the rest of the schedule for today
was at 11 o'clock I was House Bill 624
and 1 o'clock house bill
a committee work session on House Bill
15.
thank you
post Bill 624 could go on for quite a
while so
my recommendation and I want to feel the
committee is that we take a 30-minute
break
for lunch and and come back at
in a half hour
and get into Hospital 624 and then
follow that with the work session on
House Bill 15.
does anybody have any opposition to that
chair can we check with uh
representative Vos to see if he's
available
he's Prime sponsor on 624.
you see uh I don't know if he's out
there or not yeah would you let Mr
representative boss do you have any
problems uh we stopped your bill at in
30 minutes
no Mr chairman I can be here in 30
minutes thank you representative boss
then
just mute your video and your audio and
we'll continue in 30 minutes
foreign
yes
Jenny can you let Mike Bolson
yep
foreign
I want to open the public hearing on
an act decreasing the fee to file a
petition for the declared for a
declaratory ruling with a site
evaluation committee
representative boss as the prime sponsor
so I'll turn it over to representative
loss
but remind the committee that
they were only interested in the feed
part of this
what policy has been passed by the
science technology and energy committee
so representative boss
thank you Mr chairman and good afternoon
colleagues
so to focus on the financials of this
bill by the way uh for the record I'm
representative Michael Bose of Epping I
did submit written testimony on this
bill so you have all the full details
about the history of of the uh the bill
and also the policy issues involved but
to focus solely on the financial aspects
of the bill the bill does reduce an
existing
fee charged by the site evaluation
committee for
declaratory ruins there are two levels
of fees one is ten thousand five hundred
dollars for a ruling from the full
committee
and there's another one that's three
thousand dollars from a for a ruling
from a subcommittee of the full
committee
this bill reduces that fee to 250
dollars regardless of whether you get a
subcommittee or a full committee uh
declaratory ruling
to my knowledge there have only been
three declaratory rulings requested of
the committee since
2015. so the financial impact of this
bill will be extremely small
now the site evaluation committee and Ms
Diane Martin the who is chair of the
site evaluation committee as well as the
chair of the Public Utilities Commission
is on the call I believe she was earlier
anyway she can tell you the exact
amounts but the site evaluation
committee does request general fund fun
funding every year
the amounts vary I believe they have
requested 250 000 from this year's
budget Ms Martin can correct me if I'm
wrong about that in past years they have
gotten general fund amounts of 450
thousand five hundred thousand three
hundred eighty thousand various uh and
Sundry amounts
so that's the financial impact of the
bill and I'd be happy to answer any
questions
I've done an army followed by
representative abramny
questions thank you Mr chairman on
representative votes do you have any
comment on the cec's uh uh reply in the
I'll have to look that up uh I'll try to
do that and uh I'll get back to you
okay it essentially says that this is
going to cost us more money and uh give
us less money and it may make uh
make uh we will result in may result in
the need for additional meetings of the
committee therefore increasing
so I'm looking at the fiscal report uh
now and my response would be that in
the past what six years since 2015 there
have only been a request for three
declaratory rules
and I'm not even sure if they were
requests for a full committee
declaratory ruling but let's say they
were that would be about 31
500 that the committee uh has taken in
if you will from declaratory rulings
over the past six years
and uh I can't imagine that if they're
getting general fund funding every year
of from 250 to 500 000 dollars that uh
depriving them of the few dollars that
this declaratory ruling
fee drop
would result in will have that much
effect on their operations
now you could argue I suppose that
lowering the fee will stimulate more
declaratory ruling requests but there's
no there's been no indication uh from
testimony that we heard that such a an
increase would occur
hello Mr chairman oh
on
wasn't this the reason that they were on
decreasing the fee because it would keep
ordinary citizens from being able to ask
for a hearing to have to pay 10 000
something
that's exactly the reason the policy
reason for decreasing the fee is to
increase the transparency and the
accessibility of the committee to people
who otherwise not be able might not be
able to
request such a really because the fees
representative Bromley
I think you answered part of my question
with that last response because there's
five let's here are five different
um
filings
petition for committee jurisdiction when
we're talking about petition for
declaratory ruling certificates transfer
of ownership repressive exemption
requests to modify certif uh certificate
and they all seem to be basically the
same with the exception of the first one
which is just ten thousand five hundred
for a full committee review
so is there from a pure workload
standpoint
forget about the fact that there's
there's a political discussion that we
just had about allowing lowering the
feed so that more people can file but
from a workload standpoint is there a
different amount of work associated
uh for the state of for the site
evaluation committee related to each of
these five different
I'll have to defer to Ms Martin to
answer that question I don't know what
the workload of the SEC is for
anything to be honest with you okay I'll
ask her thank you
thank you any further questions
yeah I have a question representative
Ames
um
representative thank you for coming back
again
so the question is um whether testimony
was or other documents were provided to
your committee when you were reviewing
this bill
on the question of how much it actually
costs
set evaluation committee to address a
sort of an average if there's such a
thing an average request for a
so there was no testimony that indicated
how much it cost to process
a declaratory ruling it depends on the
request a declaratory ruling passes
judgment on uh usually a complaint filed
against an energy projects owner for
violating its site certificate
and
um so it it depends you know it probably
changes from request to request
depending on what the nature of the
thank you
well no thank you thank you
uh representative Union
thank you Mr chairman
um thank you representative DeVos for
taking my question
um my question is when I look at the
estimated on the fiscal note the
estimated increase or decrease
um I'm a little surprised it's
indeterminable only because we must have
historical data on roughly how many of
these
um declaratory rulings are made each
year and then therefore taking the
reductions
um isn't there a way to get that
information
well and I would imagine there is we
could certainly ask the site evaluation
committee the last time
I asked that question of the then
administrator Pamela Moore now she told
me there had been three requests since
2015.
okay follow-up all
so um then obviously if three requests
we're not talking about a huge
difference in money but therefore is is
the idea of dropping to so either people
really aren't interested in
that you know to a great degree of
getting these declaratory rulings or is
is it the belief that there's a lot of
people that want them but the price is
just too high
we did hear testimony to that effect
although I wouldn't characterize
that there were a lot of people who
wanted them
the issue is when somebody does want a
declaratory ruling if it's too expensive
for an average citizens to to get that
declaratory ruling then they're
essentially locked out of the process
which makes the whole site evaluation
committee process less transparent and
less accessible to the general public
which diminishes and this is a poly use
policy if you're not a financial one but
it diminishes The
credibility of the site evaluation
committee if people don't trust that
they're doing what they're supposed to
do correctly if they can't see what
they're doing and how can they trust and
know what they're doing
one more follow-up all so I guess my my
concern then would be I I certainly uh
transparency is certainly always a plus
I guess my concern would be we have no
way of knowing whether this will
overwhelm the system by dropping the
the
fee so low
or do we
no we do not have any way of knowing but
uh
if we use history as a guide if there
have been three requests over the past
six years that's an average of one-half
request per year then
um we can we can estimate that there
will be no the system will not be
overwhelmed
representative Bromley
thank you Mr chair uh thank you again
representative Mr chair this question
kind of gets to understanding what the
collaboratory ruling is so that we
better have make a better judgment about
what that fee should be so can I ask the
question yes what exactly is a petition
it asks typically it asks a question of
the site evaluation committee about the
about whether a site certificates terms
and conditions are being met or violated
okay
that helps thank you
thank you
um I'm I'm wrestling with the question
of how can it go
from costing ten thousand or three
thousand dollars down to two hundred and
fifty dollars
do they get a refund those people that
paid the ten thousand dollars
I I mean how much does this actually
cost do you know
I was asked that question earlier thank
you representative Elliott and I
deferred it to Ms Martin she can do a
better job of explaining exactly how
much it costs the committee to perform
one of these uh declaratory ruling
um to create a declaratory ruling uh
okay since I see no other hands and
would you let
foreign
valuation committee she's neutral on
this and she wants to testify it
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Diane Martin and as
you've heard I am the chairwoman of the
site evaluation committee as well as the
Public Utilities Commission and I am
here today essentially to answer your
questions I know that there have been a
lot of questions that I just heard
related to funding past
um number of these types of proceedings
and that kind of thing so I'm happy to
answer any and all of those questions to
the extent I have that information with
me I guess the first question is how
much does it cost for a declaratory
judgment
Okay so we've had three as
representative both said um historically
and I will preface all this by saying I
became the chair of both in the end of
2019. so I actually have not had
declaratory ruling come before me during
that time but prior to my joining there
were three and the numbers that I have
um
they range from
a little bit under two thousand dollars
in costs associated with it and the most
expensive the one with the highest cost
billed to and paid by the SEC was 10 898
dollars so it's a range and I think that
gets to the question somebody else asked
which is what does it take to do one of
these types of proceedings and and I
think the issue for the society
evaluation committee and funding it is
that it's not ever the same most cases
are entirely different and so you may be
able to resolve one case in just a few
proceedings and others may take
um a significant number of proceedings
so it really depends upon the question
that comes before the committee
and another piece I just want to quickly
explain is the committee is made up of
both agency members state agency members
and those are very high level members
so your Department of Transportation
commissioner is on the committee and
it's not her or designee it's her so we
have to have that commissioner if we're
going to have a public meeting of that
committee
um your Des commissioner is the vice
chair I'm the chair it's it's a lot of
people who also have a lot of other
things going on and so
um
those folks only get reimbursed for the
state expenses after three days of worth
of proceedings
uh you also have public members who have
to be compensated for all of their time
and every commit subcommittee has public
members so there's always going to be an
expense associated with whatever we do
in addition the statute provides for an
administrator
who obviously would be a consistent
expense throughout so
um
costs can vary I guess that's my point
and if there's no real way of saying
what what one of these would cost
you mentioned administrator do you have
an administrator at present where you're
not having these declaratory judgments
uh no the position is vacant and that's
another Point worth making there is no
other staff for the committee and so
essentially
um it's me
at the moment
so do you stack up when when required
uh the the administrator had been in
place for a few years and she just took
another position in the fall there was a
hiring freeze and we also did not have
General funding
um in this biennium there was instead a
footnote that provided for me to go to
fiscal if the fees were not sufficient
and so I I actually just went a couple
weeks ago for the first time and I was
um given about ninety five thousand
dollars for the fiscal year for this
operation and that covered the majority
of that was to cover the expenses for
that administrator while she was
actually there
well thank you uh representative bronney
thank you for your testimony
um so when you look at the five types of
uh filing fees that are listed in the
bill here only one is being changed uh
how do you how do you compare
one to the other in terms of the average
amount of work
is a declaratory ruling petition
uh less than the others
are there is there any one type of you
know uh petition for committee
jurisdiction certificate of transfer of
ownership
et cetera
they tend to take more time than than
the petition for declaratory ruling in
general
applications for certificates are I
think by far the most expensive and that
would be things like we just had the
Chinook solar project and and so there
was an application for being related to
that obviously Northern Pass was one of
the one of the applications for
certificate those tend to be larger
um proceedings that go on for longer uh
declaratory ruling I think just based
upon the numbers I'm seeing they they
look like they tend to be less
significant in the um amount of
resources required to accomplish them
an example of follow-up
uh let's use the Northern Pass example
uh what was that under that was a
certificate
yes that was an application for
certificate right so clearly that that
that went well beyond the ten thousand
five hundred that's here correct in
terms of what it cost actual expense is
that correct yes uh
uh the application fee for that was
actually and these are not definite
numbers but this is what I have in front
of me six hundred and twenty six
thousand dollars right so there's really
these fees seem to have been said a
while ago and they all seem to be
basically the same
um you know
and it's really hard to compare apples
to apples here it appears that there are
some that that will exceed
the ten thousand five hundred no
question most of the time is that is
that a correct statement
some of the different uh tapes that are
set forth in the statute yes absolutely
I think the majority will exceed that
the 10 500 that currently is established
for the petition
um
I think in this case it's really just
what I wanted to highlight is that these
fees don't
necessarily cover the costs and so
reducing the fee will obviously
um create a greater disparity to the
extent
that they don't cover the cost thank you
um I have further question on that
under section two as the filing fees
in those five different filing fees and
we're dealing only with the declarative
ruling but the other four the fees are
essentially the same how much activities
uh petition for committee jurisdiction
we have one that was just filed i i in
the time that I've been at the at the
SEC
um there has been
from my perspective very little activity
for new types of applications or filing
so we had the Chinook solar filing we've
now got a petition for committee
jurisdiction
um
and that's all we've had since I came in
in 2019. I think the distinction and the
issue that is also at play is that there
is
um a requirement of compliance with the
certificate as representative Bose
mentioned and so that involves post
certificate uh work you you won't see a
filing fee related to that because there
isn't one
um and so there's just an ongoing issue
I think related to the funding of this
committee for and the work that needs to
be done
only five different types of
committee uh Juris uh
petition for committee jurisdiction for
declarative ruling
certificate transfer request for
exemption request to modify are they
handled by the same people or different
people
so there is a group that makes up the
committee it's it's state agency members
and public
appointees and so essentially if it's a
public meeting it's generally the the
whole committee if it's one of these and
a subcommittee is permitted then then I
I can determine
which to use and assign a subcommittee
so it does vary although the committee
is consistent
and do they fade into one fund or they
have five separate funds oh the fees all
proceeding but it goes into that fund
and then it's expended from that fund
so then what would I say then that the
other four
sets of fees then would offset any loss
for the Declaration will increase
if there were an excess that could be
possible
um
that hasn't been my experience since
being there because we haven't had a lot
of filings or a petition for committee
jurisdiction that we just received was
filed by a group of residents and under
the statute that allows for filing
without a fee and so we need to do that
proceeding which will have a cost but
there is no fee related to that for
those types of filers
well thank you representative
thank you on I'm getting more questions
as we go along on it says here in the
statute that committee jurisdiction is
10 500 but you just said somewhere in
the statute I guess that if it is a
group of community members which I
thought is what this was about on that
they don't have to pay anything
yes and I apologize I don't have that
Statute in front of me at the moment but
um yes if if it is filed
um with a number of residents signing a
petition there will be no fee if the
committee accepts jurisdiction and the
project goes forward that fee can be
assigned to the actual
um
company doing the project but if the
Comm if the committee does not accept
jurisdiction that proceeding will have
had
um
[Music]
so in any of these cases on if it is
community members who put together a
petition on then they don't have to file
for a fee and if uh the ruling
is against on them then uh there would
be no money for the work you've done if
the ruling was for them then the company
would have to compensate would have to
pay the fee
you've got that right except that it is
limited to number one in the list on
section two
um no I'm yes number one petition for
committee jurisdiction the ten thousand
five hundred dollar fee that
um is the one where that applies it does
not apply in this in the petition for
declaratory ruling
setting
could could I ask a further follow-up
just quickly follow up thank you on so
if we put that same stipulation into
number two which apparently would be the
community getting together to say look
this company said that it was not going
to create a ash pit that could come down
and go into our River or something like
that on then um they would not have to
pay
to file that petition
could we put that in to there as well
and how would we do it
you could certainly create something
that would um be similar to that I have
I haven't looked at you know how that
would best be done but I think you could
certainly apply something like that to
this I'm trying to think about how
I suppose if you
well the problem is a petition for
declaratory ruling really is uh related
to the applicability of the statutes or
rules to um
to the petitioner and so
there are other statutes that play
related to what what were I'll call a
complaint
162h12 is called enforcement and it
provides for a determination that a
condition
or term of the certificate is not being
whether or not that's a declaratory
ruling I think there are differing
opinions and and I raise the point to
say under 162h12 enforcement there is no
fee for bringing that um
for bringing a complaint and and the
action is taken by the committee to
determine whether there's been a
violation so
I just want to be careful about
suggesting that petition for declaratory
ruling is the only way in which a
lack of compliance
by a company with
represents
[Music]
um thank you Mr chairman um
my question is um so as I look at these
it looks like if the full committee
rules on
um you know whichever whichever aspect
it is whether it's one two three four
five then it's a ten thousand five
hundred dollar
uh fee and it looks like if it's a
three-member board for items two through
five it would only be three thousand
presumably because the cost is less so
and I'm noticing the change to this rule
is that uh or not rule but this uh area
of the law would be 250 with no
discrimination between a full Committee
hearing it and a three-member uh
subcommittee so I guess I'd like your
opinion on
uh wouldn't it make sense for
um I don't know if the full committee is
hearing it it's it's three times
whatever the cost is you know if we
agree with the 250 then it would be 750
I suppose for the full committee 250 for
the free number and you know I mean I'm
presumably because the cost is a lot
more for the full community to hear it
the costs are without question higher if
you have a full committee because you'll
have more public members on the full
committee and um
you're going to have all you know
a larger number of folks who would have
to be paid particularly if it goes more
than three days so
um I think there is a distinction in
cost whether you reflect that in the fee
is is in the legislature's purview but I
think that the the point I'm
trying to make is that in either
scenario 750 250 it won't fund the cost
of of that proceeding it will fall short
I want to clarify on the
um
on the general funds
again I wasn't there in the last
biennium but there was a
um
a footnote that requires oh that in this
by ending there's a footnote so there
were no General funds appropriated as
part of the biennial budget there was a
footnote saying if there weren't enough
fees you need to go to fiscal and get
funding in the prior biennium there was
a
provision in the law that said that uh
up to I believe 480 000 could be spent
from the renewable energy fund and so
that money in the prior biennium came
from the renewable energy fund as
representative Bernstein
thank you Mr chair and thank you Ms
Martin for taking my question
um so let me see if I have this correct
if I file petition by myself it could
cost ten thousand five hundred or maybe
three thousand dollars
to follow that but if I get my friend
let's say uh representative Malloy to
file with me then there's no fee
whatsoever
foreign
citizens than than two that the I wish I
had the statute in front of me and I
apologize I can get you that information
but it is a larger group of residents
that have to join together sign a
petition and that has to be presented to
the committee but again that only
relates to petitions for committee
jurisdiction so it does not relate to
the petition declaratory ruling
provision that's being amended here okay
if you if you could get us the details
on that I would appreciate that I will
do that
um and
um all you follow up
I know you haven't been there that long
but how many times have you heard an
individual say hey I would have filed
but I just can't afford
the cost
I'm trying to determine maybe what
elasticity of demand is and
I I have not heard that and I have not
heard that said while I've been there
but like I said there has been a
what I would consider a lull in filings
generally for the SEC there have only
been two during the entire time I've
been there
okay thank you very much
uh representative spilsbury
it's my understanding that the
science technology committee split 1110
and that the difference uh between those
two uh groups was simply over whether
this reduction should also apply to
business interests in other words it
looked like they were all comfortable
with what we're in the fee for residents
but they were divided on the question of
business interests is that even a
I think it could be a workable
distinction
um
I mean I think the legislature could
Define these kinds of things however
however they want to like they did with
the groups of uh residents you could
come up with categories of folks for for
and follow up please
so if the distinction was workable on
some level would it make sense that the
disparity be
250 on the one hand and 10 500 on the
other hand or if the distinction was
being made would there be some different
set of figures that would make more
sense
um I think whether the legislature wants
to make it easier to access the
committee for certain types of filings
for for certain groups of people
I think that's a decision for the
legislature to make if they were to do
that
um
I think it really depends on what your
goal is do you want the business to pay
the full costs in line with what I get
read you earlier
um and the lower fee to really not
reflect costs it really I think it
really depends upon what the goal of the
legislature is related to doing that
thank you
representative followed by
representative Bromley
thank you Mr chairman on I'm getting
more and more confused about what
declaratory ruling is the petitions the
three petitions earlier where they filed
all by
by what you'd call on business interests
opposed or for the project that they
were talking about
on
I had thought that it was supposed to be
a complaint about non-compliance after
the fact but it appears that that's done
somewhere else
so there was one filed by it was a
petition for declaratory ruling of the
antrimwin opponents that was the 10
898 dollar cost there was a petition for
declaratory ruling brought by
17 towns
and in that case the costs were
5936 dollars
and
the last one was a petition
for declaratory ruling of New Hampshire
transmission LLC which would be an
entity and that was the least expensive
at one thousand six hundred forty four
dollars so I think the answer is it's
foreign
actually have a question for
representative Voss when we're at that
point
um
maybe continue dialogue
so representative Austin to take the
question
yes I'll take any questions I just want
to uh clarify representative spilsbury
[Music]
um
gave us a vote tally from your committee
but I I just double checked
it looked like it passed out of your
committee this bill passed out of your
committee 19 to 1.
am I correct on that I'm looking at that
was in it that was a typo in the house
calendar it should have been 11 to
nothing with the typo right yeah what
was the final vote
eleven to nine it was eleven nine okay
thank you Mr chair
yeah it's Diane Martin again I apologize
I need to excuse myself to to go do a
hearing
and so if it's permissible to you
um I will provide my information
to you for the committee and if and I
will also provide the information
requested by representative berstein and
any other information you need
um
I'm sorry I missed that that will be
okay okay thank you very much I
apologize
okay thank you all right have a good day
okay
um
representative Bromley are you through
your question uh well another question
yes that's fine
uh representative Army posed um
different solution
uh to this uh I just wanted your
I refresh my memory with her
um
it was to treat it like one of the
others
um
section one right the section one
remember zombie can you can you help me
out and
uh
yes we've been told that petition for
Community Committee jurisdiction on
is on the fun the fee is not required
when it is community members doing a
petition
which if it was applied to to petition
for declaratory ruling on it for the
past three that they've had two of those
groups would not would have been
Community groups and they would not have
so is the question is that an acceptable
yes that would be my question
okay I would say uh that would depend on
the number of people who are required to
sign the petition there are situations
where uh
and I can give you a concrete example if
you want the Antrim win project in
antrum there are Butters who live near
those wind turbines who believe that
those turbines are exceeding their sound
limits
but there may not be enough of them to
qualify for a petition I don't know what
the number of of petitioners has to be
but Ms Martin made it sound like that
it's more than just a few so that would
preclude those people from uh making a
complaint to the site evaluation
committee and I think that's wrong I
think that
um these people need to have access to
the committee
to address their complaints number one
and also to make the rest of us have uh
a reasonable amount of trust that the
site evaluation committee is doing its
job to protect people from
energy projects that don't follow their
would you suggest a number
number of practitioners
any further questions uh let's see if
there's anybody else
testify
I don't see anybody signed up on the
attendee list
so there's no further questions and I'm
going to close the public hearing on
on the discussion thus far today
on the five bills that we hurt
looks like we need a general work
session
and I'll look at that scheduled
foreign
committee work session on on House Bill
15 Dash FM now
we have connect relative to including
under the meals and rooms tax facilities
facilitators of Internet transactions of
motor vehicle rentals and facilitators
of Internet transactions of room offices
representative Baxter have come up with
an amendment
I believe the latest amendment is uh
Amendment 0599h
you hear me Mr chair
is the latest Amendment
zero five nine nine H I'm I'm not sure
which one is which office hop my head Mr
chair but I did just want to ask I know
representative Newman sent you an email
about if we could caucus on hb15 before
we had a work session
um and I'd just like to request that as
well
um
we can talk us if we were at the LOB
but to be able to caucus now we have to
terminate the meeting
uh I uh I think what we should do is
committee as a whole
continue the discussion
and then
when we meet
tomorrow
well when the committee as a whole
place the discussion we will
ask
the
Democrats
to leave
and Republicans to stay and then we can
caucus and then continue our discussion
after the caucus
we meet tomorrow excuse me
so Mr chair just to clarify are you
suggesting that we should caucus after
today's meeting or tomorrow well after
today's meeting
because if we if we terminated our
meeting right now
then we as a committee as a whole we
couldn't discuss it
we wouldn't be discussing house bill 15.
I would like to
discuss how spell 15 as a committee as a
whole to see what all the issues are
and then after that and then we'll end
German major yes
um
somehow we can't see you anymore
oh I forgot my oh it's your folder oh
okay sorry sorry about that
um
yeah we wouldn't be voting until
tomorrow though we wouldn't be voting
until tomorrow correct if we voted so we
will not be voting today it would be
voting tomorrow
okay Mr chair I want to hear what what
Hershel Nunes representative news thinks
about that but I think that should be
fine and I'm gonna pull up the um the
amendment number for you real quick
okay and so we will have a work session
on Hospital 15 as a full committee
and then after the work session
and we've closed the work session and we
can hold a caucus
inside uh what a position would be for
tomorrow and we hopefully we can execut
them I hope
just a question uh
we're we're on a public we're in a
public meeting on this
um site that we're on however you refer
to it and I'm I'm I want to be sure that
you can transition as you suggested into
a republican caucus without
leaving this meeting and convening your
own meeting what I would do and I would
try this is that all the Democrats drop
off
and then make sure there are no
attendees
and the only ones left would be
Republicans and then we could hold our
drop off
and then I would have to send a link to
the Republican members
and hold on
a caucus later on in the afternoon
representative major I'm sorry for
interrupting but but that is what you
will have to do we will have to turn off
this meeting
um we're not we're not able to
facilitate caucuses okay then that's
what I will do
after this meeting I would send a link
to the Republican members
to meet for a caucus later this
afternoon
okay on Hospital
represent a major there are two of us
with our hands up still from the
conversation
representative
I think they representative newness was
first and his hand is still up but
representative news
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Alami that was very kind
of you to recognize that I was waiting
um Mr chairman uh I I agree with uh
representative Baxter I do think that we
need to caucus if we're going to do a
work session today we'll just be
gathering information correct so that we
can talk about it privately uh later
because I think we have some points that
we want to bring up to you
representative
thank you if that is so we're going to
need a work session tomorrow since the
Democrats won't know
what this extra information is but I
would like to request that whatever this
amendment newest amendment is that it
gets sent to us even if it was sent to
us earlier so that when we caucus we can
look at it
and we are ready to caucus we've got a
backup system well I think the amendment
we're talking about is amendment 5998 is
that correct representative Baxter
that's correct Mr chair everybody should
have a copy of
599h
Mr chairman representative Nunes can can
we just have representative Baxter email
that to the Ways and Means Committee
again so that everybody can have a fresh
copy
thank you representative
so they share the screen now we've got
to figure out how to get it yeah just
just send it out yeah let me send that
out
okay we don't have anybody from the dra
I
pardon me representing a major but I let
all three of them in already oh you did
Mr chair It's Pat it wouldn't hurt to
have him uh put the amendment up on the
on the screen for us
all right
Jen do you have a copy of that amendment
that you can put on or Janine
I don't
um but can we can representative Baxter
do it right that's what I was gonna say
yeah
Mr chair would you like me to pull it up
or would you like me to email it to Jen
because I heard I've heard both
why don't you pull it up
because everybody should have a copy of
this
I
you can send it out later too just to
because there was
all right just give me one moment I'll
pull that up for you guys
and we need to know that dra has seen it
well we're waiting for it to come up I
just want to clarify is this the same
amendment that we looked at and we will
ask last discussing hi boys that's
correct okay so and we've discussed this
um and dra was here and it was maybe
they've had more thought about it
I'm not sure I understand why we're
going to go forward with more discussion
when it's clear that
the on the Republican side there needs
to be a discussion
and I think that's what representative
oh
representative Baxter is going to have
it pulled up
yeah Mr chair I do have the amendment
now
um so I can't pull it up if I have the
um ability to share the screen but I
know representative all me as well
suggested that we're going to need a
work session tomorrow based off what
comes from our caucus and to
representative ames's point it may make
more sense to have one work session
instead of two but I'll leave that to
you Mr chair as well as the fellow
um
can you uh see my screen Mr chair yo can
you um
to make it a little smaller so we can
see more of it there's not many lines
how about that is that better right
that's fine
all right make it a little bit larger
let's go let's go up on it
because we don't need to see your name
right there right there that's it
and Mr chair just to remind uh the
fellow committee members this is the
amendment that we discussed about before
as repetitive Ames
um brought up and this amendment was
written uh by dra
um
same same Amendment the purpose is to
make sure that we're not taxing Travel
Service agents and the change from my
original amendment is extent of
exempting by occupation it exempts by
the service provided so we don't wholly
exempt
foreign
thank you again I'm not sure exactly
what we're doing right now my
understanding is that dra does not feel
that an amendment is necessary and so
um
Carolyn or Melissa do you have a comment
or would it help
hi representative Mrs Carolyn Lear
assistant commissioner with the New
Hampshire Department of Revenue
um so I think try to summarize as best I
can where we stand
um based on our understanding which is
our feeling is that an amendment is not
necessary
um but we were asked to assist
representative Baxter with
um the creation of an amendment and we
believe that this amendment is safer at
okay it's your question
so you would have no problem with the
um
I would say that that that's an accurate
statement we'd have no problem
um with this bill being amended I
believe during the last work session
representative Ames had asked the
specific question whether this has the
potential to cause confusion and my
answer to that question was I think any
time that you add a really specific
language carving out a particular
um industry
that there's the potential to cause
confusion
um
but
I'm relatively comfortable with this as
drafted
yeah and the whole idea of the amount is
is that we needed to clarify to make
sure that travel agents were just doing
their business as travel agents weren't
being taxed
uh representative herzl Nunez
thank you Mr chairman
um I I like the amendment because I just
want to remind
um everybody and maybe uh you guys can
keep me honest
um we've talked about this uh this bill
several times now we've had a couple of
work sessions we've heard hearings we've
heard testimony
um and and it all came down to the fact
that we had questions about the travel
agents and that's why uh we went for
having an amendment to begin with is
because there was a question about the
travel agents and then in testimony from
the dra there was there was uh there was
conversation about
confusion with the rules committee
and that is where I think uh confusion
sets in for a lot of people uh if I if I
remember correctly
um our representative from the dra
didn't know whether or not the rules
committee was going to have an issue
with the original bill that's why we
went for an amendment and the First
Amendment wasn't acceptable so we worked
on the Second Amendment and this
amendment clearly states I think what
the rules committee will need in order
to make their rule around this statute
and if the if the um I I don't remember
the the
the representative's name that's with us
today because I can't see the whole
screen right now so I apologize ma'am uh
can can will you just clarify that
that's the process that we went through
in order to make sure that it was the
charge that was being talked about and
not the travel agent as whole business
per se and that's why we wanted this
amendment
um I would just clarify representative
thank you for the question my comments
about being concerned with the outcome
before the rules committee were specific
to the first amendment that
representative Baxter had drafted
um my concern was that
jailcar could interpret that language as
being broader than what was intended and
that therefore our attempts to enact
rules
um construing it narrowly
um would be seen by jailcar as not being
consistent with that Amendment we do not
have any concerns about our ability to
effectively enact rules under the bill
as drafted it was very specific to the
language in that first amendment
may I follow up Mr chairman
uh thank you ma'am um so again I'm
confused uh because uh I believe that we
wanted to make sure that we defined down
to make sure that the travel agencies
weren't being charged something they
shouldn't be charged
um and does this amendment not clarify
that
no I believe the amendment certainly
clarifies that
um I I'm not sure that this is an issue
that requires clarification
um but certainly don't get a vote in
that um that question
um I think that we could um
adequately answer the question relative
to travel agents based on how the bill
is currently drafted
thank you look Tim Baxter representative
Baxter
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
speak to
um that discussion that was just going
on and we've got a bill that's pretty
popular overall in terms of the intent
as written and the only hang up that
I've heard
um from interest groups and stakeholders
and people in my community is this
potential issue of travel agents travel
agent Services being taxed and while I
respect the dra's perspective that the
amendment isn't needed not all interest
groups and stakeholders agree with that
view which is why I felt strongly about
proposing an amendment this current
amendment is written by dra and I've
worked with them to make sure we have an
amendment that's suitable but with the
amendment that's going to alleviate the
only concern major concern that's
lingering for some interest groups and
stakeholders as well as some fellow
members on the committee and I think
with this amendment that the has written
and had that she's she's just spoke to
that she's relatively comfortable with
she did write the amendment
um I think it would it would be able to
be exact
um very easily with this amendment so
um you know I I don't I don't really see
the harm my perspective is we should do
it once and we should do it right thank
you Mr chair
well thank you represent Baxter
thank you Mr chairman there is a lot
cleaner way to do this but it it
depends on uh the members uh
understanding of how jail car works and
how the legal process works and that
would be to put into the blurb the
majority blurb on that the intent of
this bill is on
not to tax
and that would be read by jail Carr
and on would be respected by the dra if
it wasn't respected by the dra it would
be read by jail Carr and they would
would insist
on so
um it would avoid having to put into
statute of specific occupation after
which other occupations might try to say
well maybe maybe I would get involved
too
um so uh it is an alternative way to do
this which I hope the majority will
consider when you go to caucus thank you
representative news
thank you Mr chairman and to uh
representative Almy I believe the
amendment takes that out of occupation
and puts it down to the charge not to
the occupation that's what the
um
I'm not sure where where things were
left in terms of sending out that
Amendment but it seems to to all of us
so that we can have it when we're
deliberating in caucus
and I took a screenshot
Tim
would you make sure it gets out to the
Full House
all right any further discussion on this
this is looks like it's the only Hangout
on passage of Hell House bill
15.
either one
representative Hamburg
thank you Mr chair I do have a question
uh uh what does the Wayfair decision
enter into this when the facilitator is
not located within the state but is in
another state
and
will the dra be going after that
facilitator to pay the tax
uh
heard a lot of arguments when we were
discussing Wayfarer South Dakota could
come here and request our our companies
how does the Wayfarer decision play with
facilitators that are not located in the
state in New Hampshire is going to go
out and try and get the meals and rooms
money
Caroline
could you respond to that
um so certainly the Wayfair decision
um
does come into play here in that you do
have remote sellers
um located in another state
um renting property here in New
Hampshire
um in that sense I think the Wayfair
decision is
um
helpful but not strictly necessary
because I think the difference between
normal sales is um in this instance
I think we would assert that the remote
sellers do have adequate contacts here
in New Hampshire because they're
controlling the rental of property
located here in New Hampshire
um I don't know that we would really
need to rely on the Wayfair decision to
adequately
um audit and uh Sports compliance for
those remote sellers
thank you
any further discussion yeah I just had a
quick comment um
thank you I wanted to pick up on I think
it was your chair chairman Majors uh
comment that this basically a good bill
that
most if not all of us
agree with and that's great and I think
in looking at this question of language
and travel agents and
um other stuff that surrounds that we're
just all trying to get to a point
that um
that clarifies and perfects this bill
and in looking at the language that uh
has been developed the first time around
my my initial reaction was that created
potential confusion or
um or gaming gaming of the system and
but I'm going to look at it again and I
hope we all do my status at this moment
is that we're better off with the
without the amendment but I will look at
it
thank you any further questions or
comments
on Hospital 15 as the men with the
amendment
foreign
I will send a link out to the house
Republican members for a caucus this
can we say
2 30.
which is 45 minutes from now
anybody got a problem or should we go
what was the number 230
2 30. yeah
that's 45 minutes
all right Mr chairman yes representative
I'd like the Democrats to assemble I
presume we still have a working link
from representative gorg on
say 10 minutes after we close this so
that we can not interfere in the middle
of the rest of our afternoon
thank you can be sent again by
representative gork of course thank you
Mr chair yes
uh can you tell us what we're doing
tomorrow Beyond this bill
oh
the big thing tomorrow there's a couple
of things we have to look at
the information of
single sales Factor ratio
so we also want to look at all the
and and anything else to do with the
revenue implications
can I uh can I chime in on that
satisfactor thing yes
so we we passed House Bill 281 out of
out of ways it means 22 to nothing which
extends the date out
to 2026 from 2022.
the finance committee is now looking at
that
and asking us
if they put this into house bill 2.
House Bill 281 into house bill 2.
that uh they're asking what do we think
the impact would be on our Revenue
estimates for
2023. right I sent that to all members
of the House of rising Means Committee
okay but I just want to make sure
everybody understands and hopefully
everybody thinks about that
um I know I personally
uh reduce my estimates
when I when I did mine uh because of of
uh of uh
uh a single sales Factor
but if there's not going to be single
sales Factor
meaning nothing is going to change from
existing other than market-based
sourcing which is in place this year
does that change people's thinking about
about 23 fiscal 23 for a single sales
factor that that's that's what we're
going to talk about tomorrow one of the
and we need to come up with something
further to help finance committee out on
this
all right anything else I want to bring
up before we terminate this
then uh so what time is it now
I think we'll stick with 2 30 for the
Republicans to meet
and I'll send you out send you out the
link
thank you everybody